안녕하십니까 최미탄 여러분 행복한
투자 예정을 함께하는 체슬리 모닝
브리프 7월 8일
1부 시작하겠습니다.
전일 중국시장 왕정부장님과 함께
보겠습니다.네
>> 어제는 태그 주 하나하면서 상 지수
맨너스 1.3% 빠졌고요. 항상 태극
지수 매너스 0.75% 75% 하하고
정식 관리대금도 거의 2조까지
내려갔습니다. 업종별 중 보시면
커뮤니케이션 IT 유틸 업정이
상대적인 컨셉 배웠으면 부동산
헬스케어 소재 업정이 약세
배웠습니다. 어 2번기 실적
기대감으로 광통신 관련주 어제 반등
나오고요. 종재 5천은 플러스 2%
올라고 신 역수는 염증이 5%
천부신는 3% 각각이 돌아왔어요. 어
중국 반도체 고생화 확대 등기 때문에
일부 반도체 권능 조도 올라왔습니다.
기는 + 1% 항공은 1%
상했는 + 6.3% 3% 화도체는
4정이 5% 나왔고요. 어 기계 수출
데이터 허조로 기계 권연주 어제도
강세되었습니다. 세밀 중고업는 +
3% 기계는 거의 4% 가까이
올라왔어요. 저가 매수 자금 요입으로
게임주도 돈방은 강세로 보였습니다.
어 세기 화통는 3%하고 거의
네트워크 6% 몰라왔습니다. 특히는
그 센슨트 있잖아요.
>> 슨트는 중 대표적인 게임주로 보고
있잖아요. 5일 9% 가가이고
올라왔습니다. 그래서이 이슈 때문에
중국 관련 게임 구주들이 또 반등
나왔습니다.
>> 이번기 실적 기대감으로 2차 청지
소재 관련주도 올라왔어요. 승사 청등
신소재는 + 1% 바텔레는 1.4%
넘쳐 주시는 4% 올라왔어요. 반면은
PCB CCR 관련주들이 좀
빠졌어요. 승인테크는 매너스 2%
성전도는 매너 5% 빠졌어요. 정시
거래대금 감소등 요인으로 정권주도
빠졌습니다. 중신 정권은 -2.7%
7%번 재는 4% 빠졌어요. 어제는
신념물 구체 금리 그리고 이념물 구체
금리 다 유지했습니다. 외양화 환율은
염정 2% 소폭 전화되었습니다.
>> 감사합니다.
어제 한국은 어 반도체 중심으로
낙폭이 굉장히 크게 나와서 물론 어
영향력이 뭐 레버리지 ETF 때문에
그렇다곤 하지만 매도 사이드 카드
나오고 서킷 브레이커 나오고
>> 아 굉장히 크게 하락을 했던 장인데
확실히 중국은 어 시장이 상대적으로
변동성이 낮아 보이고
>> 맞아요.
>> 그 이유는
>> 그 이유는 금융주 비중은 높아서
그럽니다. 네. 지금 CS300
업종적으로 보시면 금융 비준 거의 2
25% 차지하고 있잖아요.
>> 산업제는 19% 필 소비때 14%
그래서이 부분은 빠지지 않하면은 시장
큰 변동이 없습니다.
>> 음. 네. 중국이 어저께 어 반도체
국산화라고 하는게 한국에서도
>> 어 장중인가요? 딥크가 자체
>> 아 집개발.
>> 네. 네. 그런 이슈인가요? 아니면
그 밖에 또 어떤 소식들이
있었습니까? 네. 그 이슈도 있고
그리고 충구의 모델 개발하는 회사들이
원래는 그 집 그 엔비디아 그 집 좀
써야 되잖아요. 요즘에 그 중국
고산칩니까
다 고산치료로 봐오고 있습니다.
그래서이이 때문에 모한게 이런
회사들이 주가는 계속 올라오고
있어요.
>> 음. 오늘 아침에 조관 신문 조관
경제 신문을 보니까
>> 창신 메모리가 원래는 중국의 반도체
공급을 할 때 그냥 기본적인 디램
공급만 했었는데
>> 10c센트로 서버용 디램도 이제
공급을 대규모를 할 것 같다. 그런
뉴스를 받거든요. 근데 어 우리
샤오미 마 샤오미 네오보 이런네
레노보 이런 그 반도체가 원재료인
기업들 말씀해 주실 때 워낙에 반도체
가격이 높아서 실적 개선되기가 어렵다
이런 말씀 주셨는데
>> 중국 기업에게 반도체를 공급을 받으면
개선의 속도나 폭이 좀 더
나아질까요?음
음
가능성 좀 있긴 있는데요. 근데 지금
>> 크게 싸지 싸기는 안 팔까 창신도
>> 지금이 어퍼는 서원은 정세 그
>> 입이 높은 수준까지 올라가잖아요.
굳이 여기 더 싸게 공급할 필요가
없고 다만 뭐가 뭐 전 세계 평균치
대비는 20% 10%을 사게 할 수
있지만
>> 뭐 50% 40% 그 할 필요가 없으
>> 맞아요. 그리고 지금 공급 쇼티지
상황은 그냥 마다고 생각해야 합니다.
>> 음. 알겠습니다. 오랜만에 하나만 더
여쭤 볼게요. 때는 우리
>> 중국 기업들 중에서 중국의 거대
제약주들
어 주목을 많이 받았던
>> 때가 있었는데
>> 네.
>> 요즘은 한국의 한국 증권사들 중에서
중국 커버해 주신 애널리스트분들의
리포트 보나 우리 왕부장을 보나
제약주 얘기는 거의 안 하는 거
같아.
>> 아 거의 안 하는
>> 어 이유가 있습니까?
이유가 되게 많고요.
둘이 아니라 되게 많아.
>> 네. 많고요.이 마이오제아주는 실전은
계속 꾸빠꾸박 잘 나오고 있고 뭐
배아 제 뭐 하스케어 관련주들이
조용사도 있고 나봉 회사도 있고요.
조용 회사는 계속 양구 개발 천하고
자사 좀 매하고 나은 회사는 실적
잘못 나오잖아요. 대주주 계속 집을
매가하고 그 두 종료도 좀 잘 봐야
하고요.
>> 어 다만 그 대주주 매도 이유가 아마
여러 가지 있어요. 뭐가 그 미국
제재 이슈오도 있고 그래서 이거도이
와인도 되게 많고요. 충분 옛날에음
이거 공포범 있잖아요. 이거는 되게
>> 아마 최소 5년 전부터 시작했어요.
대령 구매잖아요. 싸게 등고
>> 그때부터는 정체 그이 어펑 그리고
전망
>> 다 깨줬어요.
>> 아
>> 그때 대령 구매하면은
>> 원래 공급 제압 뭐이 아픈 이런 거는
가격은 90% 까가라고 하라고
했었네요. 그래서이 야간은 90%는
진짜 빠졌어요.
>> 아,
>> 네. 이런 식으로 하니까 되게
불안불안해요.
>> 그래서 요즘에 충구 제학회자 개발하는
신야들이 또 거의 거기서 걱정되고요.
확신 또 추가적으로 하라고 하면
어떻게 되냐고.
>> 그래서 이거 되게 저핑가 되고 있는
상황인 거 같아.
>> 아, 네.
>> 수년 전이죠. 저희 한국에서 그
중국의 임플란트 수출하던 기억들이
>> 어, VBP였나요? 예. 뭐 볼륨
베이스 퍼추스인가?
>> 네. 그랬던 거 같아요. 예. 그래서
어 엄청 싸게 임플란트 공급하라고
하니까 뭐 규모는 늘어날지 모르지만
마진 훼손된다고 한번
>> 주저 안 닿던 적이 있는데
>> 그게 임플란트 한국에서 수출하는 기업
그 중국 입장에서 보면 외국
기업에게만 적용한 건 아니군요.
>> 맞습니다.
>> 네.
>> 그런 전체적인 어 업항의 어떤 큰
트에서의 제약 조건이 있으니까
>> 실적이 잘 나와도 선 손이 안 나갈
것 같습니다.
>> 네. 알겠습니다. 오랜만에 제약
산업도 얘기 간다니.
왜웃수돼?
>> 아유 그 예 좀 어려운 어
>> 알겠습니다. 오늘 이시 종목은요
유리.네 네. 요리는 2015
2025년 1월 달은 그대는 하는
수가했습니다. 거의 1년 정도 이상
지나갔어요.이 회사는 충구 최대
자동차 요리 승찬 기업이고요. 중국
시장 MS는 70% 정도 되고 글로벌
MS는 38% 정도 됩니다. 어 최근
주관은 좀 많이 내려왔어요. 포더
피안는 12배 가격이 없습니다.
>> 1번기 매출에는 동의배 5% 증가하고
순위 있는 동일 대비 15.7%
7포스는 감소했습니다. 헌차수 등
1승인종이고요.이
부분 제외하면은 수익이 동의. 8%
증가 시장 대충 예상시 보화
수준입니다. 음
>> GP 마진율 32.5%됐고
동의 2% 확대했습니다. MP 마진는
12.5%나 5%나 동일 대비 4%
정도 빠졌고요. 어 거마진 어 거마진
제 자동사용 요리 매출 비중 화대 등
때문에 GP 마중 계산되었고요.
1번기 충구 자동차 승량은 동의비
요즘 9% 감소했어요. 다만이 회사용
요리 판매량은 동일대비 3.7% 바에
안 빠졌어요. ASP는 또 동일 대비
11% 올라왔습니다.
>> BS 디포트 좀 보면은 2분기도
비슷한 GP 마진 요지 가능성이
있습니다. 아마 외양화 절산에 따라서
피률를 부지 예상입니다.
>> 어 충구 자동차 업체 수출 데이터 좀
보면 3번기 수준의 개선 가능성 좀
있고요. 특히는 붐는 동의어도
10% 이상 증가 가능성이 있고요.
시장 MS는가 37% 27% 정도
보고 있습니다. 원래 ASP 인상포는
양간 목표치의 6%부터 7% 대비는
좀 상호의 가능성도 있고요. 반면은
2번기 중국 군 자동차 패배 부에
따라서 원래 내년 내년 순 있는
전망치 가가 4% 5% 정도 하향
조정했어요. 타켄을 2027년 18배
PR 적용해서 TP는 85 정도
제시했습니다. 지점 대비는 9% 정도
하원 조정하고 어제 종가 대비는
68% 정도 있습니다. 어 정염
마르키 중 배당 승량은 거의 60%
정도고요. 만약에 60% 가정하면
원래는 예산 배당 수익률는 거의
4.5% 정도 나올 수 있습니다.
>> 음.
>> 그 PR 차트 PBR 차트 좀 보면은
거의 최하단까지 내려왔어요.
>> 음. 감사합니다. 고교 유리는
>> 어 유리 생산 업체인데
>> 전방 산업이 100% 자동차인가요?
>> 아 거의 다 자동차입니다.
>> 아 그냥 거의 다 자동차다. 이렇게
보면 돼요. 그러면 자동차 대수가
중요한 거네. 어 저도 그렇게
생각하고 있지만음이
글로벌 짐토는 계속 높아지고
있어요.이 회사가 왜냐면이 글로벌
1등 회사잖아요. 2등 회사 3등은
재무 그조가 되게 많고 그래서 케파
정전을 못 했어요. MS도 화대하고
있고
>> 그리고 요즘에 그 전기 차종 보면은
요리는 완전 그 거 요리를 받고
있어요. 그거 안에서 보면은 뭐 어
파로나마
>> 이런 거 그 뭐 산루프 이런 거
있잖아요. 그리고 HUD 있는 거
>> 그 뭐 화면 표시할 수 있 디지털
표시할 수 있는 요리 이런 거 바고
수 있으니까
>> 대수보다는요
>> 대수 리스크는 뭐 좀 해제하고
있어요. 예. 그래서이 보면은
전반적으로 생산하는 개수를 줄이고
있지만이 호산드 매출는 오라하고
있습니다.
>> 음. 그 QP 이렇게 분석을 해 보면
Q는 썩기를 안 하는데 P가 좋아지고
있다.
>> 네. Q는 전반적으로 빠지고 있는데이
시전은이 호사는 시전 MS도
화대하니까 좀 성중했어요. 네.
그래서 Q도 거의 낫지 않다고. 네.
자동차 유리가 어 물론 이제 그냥
집에서 아파트 같은데 끼어 있는
유리보다는 뭐 안전성이라든지 뭐 여러
가지 그 기능들이 있어야 되기 때문에
고부가 같이 제품인 건 알고
있는데요. 네. 그래도 부게나 부피에
비해서 그렇게 가격이 높은 제품은
아니어서
>> 전 세계에서 1등을 하려면 어
공급받으려고 하는 자동차가 제조되는
곳 옆에 갖고서 공장을 지어야 되는데
>> 전 세계적으로 공장을 갖고 있어야
된다는 얘기네맞.네 네, 맞습니다.
그래서 도움이 많이 쓰고 있고요.
이번에 그 관세 때문에 미국 가서도
공연 치겠다고 그렇게 얘기했어요.
그래서이 그 투자
많이지 투자 집는 좀 많이 하고 있는
상황이고
>> 음. 어 제가 걱정하는 부분에도 여러
가지 있습니다.이 회사가 지금 1번
기준으로 하면 영업 현금 컬럼는 동의
많이 줄였어요. 줄이는 이유가 전방
업체는 좋지 않았어요. 아
>> 전방 후방 후방 어 후방 그 자동차
충구 자동차 업체들이 지금 청산량
줄리고 있잖아요. 그 자궁 회수 면접
생길 수 있어요. 외서 매출에 증가
아닌가?
이렇게 하면은 좀 문제가 생길고
그리고 미국 가서 공량도 제어하고
돈도 필요하고 그래서이 형성 자산은
그렇게 높지 않아 많지 않고요.
그래서 자금 조달 아마 가능성이
있다고 생각해요. 아,
>> 보통은 그래서 한국에도 이제
KCC라고 하는 이제 화학 업체가
유리를 물론 건축용, 그 산업용 전부
다 하지만 어, 현대차 그룹의 유리를
공급하는 업체인데 요렇게 사실은
자동차 유리하는 회사는
>> 엄청나게이 마진을 높게 이제 가져가기
좀 어렵기 때문에 대신에 이제
자동차가 매년 팔리니까
>> 웬만해선 비즈니스가 역행도 없다.
그래서
>> 어 매출이 급격하게 기여되고 이익이
크게 늘어나고 이런 걸 기대하면서
투자하기보다는
>> 음
>> 어 완만하게 실적이 상향되면서 꾸준히
현금흐름을 만들어서 그거를 주주들에게
상당히 많이 돌려 준다 이런 컨셉인데
>> 우리 왕부장님 말씀하시는 거 보니까
단기적으로는 그런 어떤 현금 어
프리캐시플로우 그니까 자유 현금 흐름
창출 능력이 조금 줄어드는 구면인가
봐요.
>> 네. 지금 PR pbr 샷부는 되게
매력이 좀 있다고 생각할 수 있는데
그는 그런 리스크 있다고 생각할 수
또 생각해야 합니다. 그래서 이제
밸루에이션도 보면 PER PBR 전부
다 좀 하단에 이제 접해져 있는데
이럴 때가 또 기회일 수 있으니깐요.
그죠? 그래서
>> 어 자금 조달 문제라든지 아니면 전방
산업이 더 이상 악화되지 않을 때
>> 어 배당 수익률도 좋고 또 주주들에게
돌려주는 것 자체에 대해서는 어
시장하고 소통이 잘되는 기업이니까
또이 마켓이 아 시장이 종목이 확산될
때 주목을 받을 수 있겠습니다.
>> 네.
>> 네. 여기까지 알아보고 미국 시장으로
넘어가겠습니다. 새벽에 또 안 좋은
한데 미국 시장 어떻게 끝났는지 우리
창민 프로와 함께 보겠습니다.
>> 네. 전일 미국 시장
말씀드리겠습니다. 전일 미국 시장은
중동 시장이 다시 구조되면서 주가가
급등하고 반도체를 중심으로 기술주
매도세가 나온 하루였습니다. 주요
지수 먼저 보시면 S&P 500이
0.45% 나스닥이 1.16% 다우
지수가 0.25% 5% 하락했습니다.
무엇보다 필반 지수가 4.65%
급락하면서 어제 반등분을 하루 만에
전부 반납하는 모습 보였습니다. 이제
주요 하락 원인으로는 호르무주
회협에서 유조선 두 척이 피격당한
사건이 있었는데이 내용은 뒤에서
자세히 말씀드릴 거고요. 다음으로
우측 섹터 쪽 보시면 어제와 정확히
반대 그림을 보이고 있습니다.
에너지가 3% 오르면서 상승하는 모습
보였고요. 건강 관리, 부동산, 필수
소비제, 유틸리티 같은 방어 섹터가
같이 오르는 모습 보였습니다. 반대로
산업제가 1.7%,
정보 기술이 1.6% 내리면서 지수를
내리는 모습을 보였고요. 어제는
방어주에서 기술주로 돈이 이동하는
모습이었다면 오늘은 그 자금이
에너지와 방어주로 옮겨간 하루였다고
말씀드리겠습니다.
다음으로 금리하고 유가 보겠습니다.
10년물 국채 금리가 4.55%로
5%로 8b 넘게 뛰면서 아주 만에
가장 높은 수준까지 올라왔고요. 가발
인플레이션 오려가 금리를 밀어올린
모습으로 보이고 이게 다시 기술주
밸루에이션 부담으로 연결되는 그런
시장 모습을 보였습니다. 유가는
WTI가 5% 오른 72달러대 브랜트
유구는 5% 상승으로 동일 상승한
채에 마음했습니다.
다음으로 왼쪽 빅테크 및 주요 종목
보시면 전반적으로 완만한 상승세
보이고 있었는데 테슬라가 4%
하락하는 모습 보였고요. 메타가
2.5% 상승하는 모습 보여줬습니다.
다음으로 반도치는 1제 하락세를
보였습니다. 마이크론이 4.7%
AMD가 6.5% 램리서치가 6.9%
그리고 인텔릭 9.7%로 7%로
급락하는 모습 보였고요. 어제 강했던
AI 인프라 종목들이 전부 되밀리는
모습 보였습니다. 새로운 낙재가
나왔다기보다는 유가발 금리 상승이 좀
밸루에이션 부담이 큰 반도체의 차익
실현 빌미를 준 영향이라고
생각했습니다.
어 다음으로 오늘 시장을 움직인
후름부 해업 상황에 대해서 자세히
짚어 드리겠습니다. 먼저 배경부터
정리해 드리면 미국하고 이란이 지난달
17일 종전 양해 각사에 서명하고
60일간 최종 합의를 위한 후석
협상에 들어간 상태였는데이
협상의 대가로 이란산 원료의 생산
인도 판매를 허용하는 60일짜리 임시
일반 면허을 발급했었습니다.
그래서 그동안 일하는 미국의 제재로
원유 수출하고 달러 결제가 막혀
있었고 중국 등의 할인 가격에 우해
판매를 해 왔었는데이 면허로
국제시장에서 시장 가격에 달러를 받고
공식 판매할 수 있는 길이
열렸었거든요. 그런데이 합의가 계속
삐걱되고 있습니다. 지난
>> 달 25일에도 이란이 해협에서 상선을
공격하고 미국이 보복 공습에 나서면서
한 차례 충돌이 있었고 양측은
28일에 일주일간 공격을 중단하기로
합의하고 30일에 도하에서 회담을
했지만 음
>> 통행료 문제에서 진전을 보지 못하는
모습이었습니다.
>> 음. 그리고 어제 그 일주일 합의가
만료된 직후에 오만해안 인근에서
유조선 한척이 발사체에 맞아 화제가
났고 또 다른 상선 한척도 일한
미사일에 피격됐습니다. 이렇게 되면서
시장이 보는 리스크는 두 가지로
보이는데요. 하나는 미국의 군사적
보복 가능성이고 다른 하나는 방금
말씀드린 원유 제재 면제가게 취소되고
제재가 보건될 가능성입니다. 어느
쪽이든 일한산 원유의 시장 복귀가
무선되고 해업 통황 불안이 좀 장기가
된다는 뜻으로 보여서 유가가 뛰고
금리에도 영향을 준 것으로 보입니다.
다음으로 아마존 관련 이슈
말씀드리겠습니다. 아마존이 달러와
채권 발행으로 최소 25밀리언 달러
조달을 추진하고 있습니다. 목적은
AI 인프라 투자 확대이고 수요에
따라 규모가 더 커질 수 있음을
얘기했으나 최종 확정은 아직 아닌
상태로 보였다. 아 이런 이슈가
하이퍼스켈러들이 AI팩스 제원을
현금흐름을 넘어서 채권 시장에서도
조달하기 시작했다는 신호로 보이고요.
KF팩스 사이클이 계속된다는 점에서는
AI 밸류체인의 긍정적 요인으로
작용할 것으로 보이고 있습니다.
다음으로 개별 종목 말씀드리겠습니다.
먼저 에너지 쪽에서 옥시덴탈이 장중
4% 가까이 올랐고요. 50달러선
회복했습니다. 직접적인 이유로는
호르무주발 유가 급등으로 보이고요.
다만 같은 유가 상승인데도 옥시덴탈이
특히 부각되는 이유는 유가 민감도가
좀 가장 좀 높은 대형 산유주의기
때문입니다. 게다가 생산 기반이
중동이 아니라 그 미국 육상에서
생산을 하는 기반이라 포르무주발 중동
공급 차질이 커질수록 오히려 대체
공급원으로 수혜를 보는 종목으로
말씀드리겠습니다.
그리고 같은 논리로 엑슨 모빌이
3.8% 세브론이 3.5% 동반
상승하는 모습 보이면서 에너지 섹터
전반이 강했습니다.
다음으로 메타인데 기술주가 전반적으로
빠지는 장에서 2%대 상승을
보였습니다. 이후로는 첫 자체 이미지
생성 모델인 뮤즈 이미지 출시인데요.
작년에 만든 조직인 슈퍼 인텔리전스
랩스가 언어 모델을 내놨었는데 이번에
이미지 모델을 두 번째로
내놓았거든요.
>> 그래서 그동안 메타가 이미지 생성을
외부 모델에 의존해 왔었는데 이걸
자체 모델로 바꾼게 주가의 긍정적인
요인으로 작용한 것으로 보입니다.
>> 음.
그래서 정리하면 오늘은 호르무주
유조선 피격이라는 지정화 이벤트와
이벤트가 유가와 금리를 밀어올렸고
하루만에 기술주에서 에너지 방어주로
자금이 이동한 정이라고 요약드리고
요약드릴 수 있겠습니다.
>> 음.
그리고 메타처럼 AI 수익화 재료가
있는 종목도 역행해서 올랐다는 점이
눈에 띄이고요. 내일 새벽에 6 UR
FOMC 의사록이 나오는데 어 유가발
인플레이션 우려가 좀 커진 시점이라서
연준의 물가 인식을 좀 확인하는
이벤트가 되고 꼭
>> 주시할 필요가 있겠습니다.
이상입니다.
>> 감사합니다.
저는이 표를 보여 주시면 제일 먼저
유가하고 국제 10년을 보는데 어
전부 다 주식 시장이 좋아하지 않는
방향으로 움직였고 어 방향뿐만 아니라
그 레벨 자체도 이제 금리가 4.5%
이상을 상하기 때문에 시장에서는
굉장히 불편한 반응을 보였을 거다.
큰 틀에선 그렇게 보여지네요. 나머지
개별 종목들에 대한 이슈 언급도 매우
감사드립니다.
미국은 2부에서 우리 최부사장님과
함께 좀 더 자세히 보기로 하고
가상자산으로 넘어가 보겠습니다.
>> 네. 가정자 시장 말씀드리겠습니다.
가격 흐름부터 보시면 24시간 동안
한 63,000불 정도에 어 위치를
하고 있기 때문에 가격 흐름은 크게
변화가 없었다라고 보시면 될 거
같은데 이게 한 6만 4,000불
이상을 돌파했다가 어 막고 내려온
걸로 봤을 때 어 저가 65,000불
정도를 저항선으로 생각하면 된다.
그리고 그 밑에는 200일선이 지지를
받고 있다. 이렇게 말씀드렸었는데 그
선을 좀 비교적 잘 지키고 있는 모습
확인할 수 있을 것 같습니다.
그래서이 65,000불을 돌파하냐 못
하냐 이게 어 그 가장 큰 화두로
보이고요. 어 어제 호르모 제협에서
관련된 뉴스들이 나왔음에도 충돌이
나왔음에도 불구하고 비트 가격은 크의
반응 없었습니다. 어 제가 생각할 때
굉장히 긍정적이라 긍정적인
부분이다라고 생각하는데 우선 유동성주
부분에서 가장 주목해 봐야 되는
크립토에서 특히 그리고 비트코인에서
어 가장자산이 그 반응이 없다라는
거는 이제 시장에서 어 호르무즈
해업에 대한 이슈에 대해서 실뢰도가
많이 떨었다라고 해석할 수 있을 것
같습니다. 그래서 유가의 상승폭도
굉장히 제한적이라고 저 보고 있고
2월 달 그 3월 달 넘어오면서
저희가 어 봤던 그 그 유가와 어
그런 호르무지 해업 관련된 뉴스들로
인해서 반응하는 비트코인이나 위험
자산 어 지금 상황보다는 훨씬 더
진정됐고 어 더 신뢰도가 많이
떨어져서 반응이 좀 덜한 상황이다
이렇게 전 해석할 수 있을 것
같습니다.
>> 오른쪽에 있는 비트코인 주봉 차트
보시면 제가 선을 두 개 그어 놨는데
이게 매물대가 좀 많은 선을 그냥
채널로 한번 그어 본 겁니다.이 이
채널로 봤을 때는이 65,000불이
저기 두 밑에 있는 선이다라고 보시면
될 거 같은데이 밑에 있는 선은
계속해서 트라이하고 있다는 점은
굉장히 긍정적이다 볼 수 있을 것
같고요. 여기를 저항을 어 이겨내지
못하고 다시 내려온다라고 하는 것
그리고 200일선을 뚫고 내려온다라고
하면 다시 한번 장기적으로 기술적으로
어 안 좋은 흐름을 보여줄 수는
있지만 어쨌든이 65,000불 어이
라인을 계속해서 트라이하고 있다는
것은 굉장히 긍정적으로 보이고요.
어, 기술적으로는 이더리움 차트도
어, 굉장히 긍정적으로 보이고는
있습니다. 그래서 오히려 상황 자체는
올해 만약에 어, 상황이 좋아진다.
그리고 크립토 쪽에 유동성이
들어온다라고 하면 한다면 어, 오히려
이더리움이 더 강하게 치고 나갈 수
있다라는 점은 참고해서 보시면 될 거
같고요. 결국에 가장 중요한 점은
반도체 쪽을 쏠림이 지금 완화가 되고
있는 어 상황이 어 미증시 그리고
국내 증시에서도 이뤄지고 있다라고
생각을 하고 있는데 그런 흐름들이
크립트 쪽으로 유동성이 들어오느냐는
저희가 한번 체크해 볼 필요는 있지만
어쨌든 지금 크립토는 가격을 좀
견적하게 지켜주고 있고 어 미증시나
그 국내 증시 같은 경우는 조금
빠지고 있다는 부분 빠지고 있다는
부분이 어 디커플링까진 아니지만
그래도 비트코인 가격이 굉장히 좋은
흐름인 흐름인 건 맞다라고 설명드릴
수 있을 것 같습니다. 하나 맞지면
비트코인이 어 긍정적인 흐름으로 가고
있는 이유를 한번 설명드리면 될 거
같은데요. 어제 안 그래도 어프가
계속해서 막 밑밥을 까는 그런
까는듯한 어 그런 모습을 보여줬었는데
알고 보니까 SEC가 그 크립토 핵심
면제 그 관련된 세이파버 같은 것들을
발표할 예정이다라고 어 어제 어제
발표를 해 줬습니다. 그래서 이달
내에 어 크립토 벤처들이나 크립토
관련된 프로젝트들이 SEC에 어 그냥
뜬거없이 규제를 받거나 어 법에
관련돼서 뭔가 저촉되는 그런 어
이슈들이 없도록 어 뭔가 면제 안을
제한해 주겠다라고 올 이번 달 안에
발표해 주겠다라고 어 발표를 해 준
상황이고요. 어 그래서 그런 부분들은
비트코인 가격이 하방이 조금 잡히는데
또는 하락폭이 제한적인데 조금 영향을
미치고 있지 않나는 생각은 하고
있습니다. 어, 비트코인 피어 그리드
인덱스 보시면 어, 그 피어 구간에
입고 한 27 정도를 기록하고
있고요. 어, 그리고 덩달아서 ETF
쪽에서도 유입이 들어오다 보니까 좀
긍정적인 흐름이 어, 지속이 되고
있는 거 같습니다. 어, 그래서 7월
6일 날 어, 265년 정도가
들어오게 되면서 ETF가 드디어 이제
터널라운드 하나 어, 이런 흐름도
어, 덩달아서 같이 비트코인 그
견조한 가격에 영향을 미쳤다라고
생각을 하고요. 어 주요 쪽 내려와서
보시면이 상상인 증권는 김경태
위원님께서 매수 시기가 근접했고
조금만 더 인내하자라는 그런 리포트를
내주셔서 뭔가 이게 크립토를 매수하는
신호로 삼자라기보다는 어 지난 그
사이클에서는 바닥을 어떻게 잡았었고
그때 분위기가 어땠었는지 어 주요
농들을 한번 소개시켜 드리러
가져왔습니다. 어 비트코인 바닥은
매우 근접했고 그러나 추세 전환
확인은 하십니다. 어, 현재 비트코인
64,000불 정도 부근에서
거래되면서 그간 기다렸던 구조상
바닥권에 근접했다라고 하는데 어
상상인 증권 크립토 심리 지수는
32.8 정도로 매수 바닥 구간인
25에 한 증 더 다가섰고 보유자의
손실 비중은 46.7%로 과거에
매도세가 소진되었던 바닥 근처 국면에
진입했다라고 합니다. 손실 물량이
46.7%이 7%이 정도로
증가했다라는 것은 겉으로 보면
부정적일 수 있지만 사실상 큰 손실을
감수하고 매도할 의향이 있던
참여자들은 거의 시장을 이제
손절하면서 이탈을 했고 매도세가
점진적으로 소진되면서 저점 매수를
노린 자금이 서서히 증가하는 양상으로
이어지기 때문에 투매 압력의 감소가
이루어질 수 있다라고 설명
비중이 67 46.7%라는 거는
46.7%는 7%는 그냥 자기 평 그
다 손실을 보고 있다라고 보시면 될
거 같고 이게 정말 심하이 갔을 때는
55% 또는 60% 정도까지 간사례는
있다라고 합니다. 어 그래서 지금
보면 1천개 이상의 비트코을 갖고
있는 초대형 고래는 순매수를 지속
중에 있으나 어 최근 매수 강도는 좀
소폭 약세되었다. 소프 약세의
흐름으로 가고 있다라고 하고 최근
60일 동안 어 60일 평균으로 봤을
때 초대형 고래가 한 47,000
비트코인 정도 샀는데 6월 23일
날에는 한 어 67,000 어
6,000 비트코인 정도 샀다라고
하니까 최근 흐름으로 봤을 때는이
매수 자체가 한 20% 정도 빠진
상황이다라고 언급을 주시고 있습니다.
실현 가치를 보유 기간별로 분해하면
어 구조가 뒷받침 되는데 단기
보유자의 실현 가치 비중은 점점 어
축 정점 대비 축소가 되고 있고 중기
대역이 빠르게 확세되고 있다라고
합니다. 그래서 단기적으로 어차피
손실 보고 있는 건 동일하지만
장기적으로 손실 보고 있는 사람이
중기 쪽으로 넘어오고 있는 흐름을
설명을 주고 계시고요. 이거는 제가
지난번에도 한번 차트로 한번 말씀드린
적이 있었던 거 같습니다.이는
이는 2025년 상승기에 매입대
물량이 조정 국면에서 손절이 없이
중기 보유자로 이연되면서 비용 기저가
좀 축족되고 있는 흐름은 가고
있다라고 설명을 해 주시면서 고래의
물량 흡수와 결을 같이 하는 긍정적
신호다라고 말씀 주셨습니다. 어
하지만 부정적인 부분도 있는데요. 어
현재 SOP 그러니까 단기이 손실
비중 어 장단기 손실 비중이라고 하는
차트 이제 지표인데 이게 0.8 8
정도를 기록하고 있고요. 이게 한 1
정도 이상을 가야 긍정적인 부분이라
보실 수 있을 것 같습니다. 그
코인베이스 프리미엄도 음수에 있고
코인베이스 프리 프리미엄 같은
경우에는 미국 기관들이 대표적으로 어
매집을 하는지 못하는지에 대한 어
수치를 비교할 수 있는 건데 양수에
있을 때가 기관들이 매집을 하고
있다는 신호로 저희가 받아들일 수가
있습니다. 하지만 그 지수가 지금
음수에 있다라고 하고요. 스티블코인
시가 총행이 정체라는 점에서 추세
전환을 확신하기 어렵고 추정 레버리지
비율이 0.24 이사 정도에 있어서
사이클 보점권까지 상승했다라고 하고
유동성이 스트레티지 및 기관 현물
수요보다 파생 중심 어 레버리지
비율이 높다 보니까 화생 시장
중심이라는 점도 좀 부담이 된다라고
말씀 주셨습니다. 한 가지이 문장에서
조금 모아했던 점은 스테이블코인 시가
총이 정체라고 말씀을 주시긴 했는데
어이 앞 전후 관계가 좀 다를 수도
있다라고 생각을 저는 개인적으로
합니다. 그래서 비트코인 시장 자체가
좋아지면 어 스테이블코인 시가 총액이
어 덩달아서 올릴 수 있는 부분들이
분명히 있기 때문에 스테이블코인 시가
총액이 정체여서 비트코인 가격이 좋지
않다라는 점은 전후에 조금 모구할
수도 있다라는 점은 제가 생각을
개인적으로 했습니다. 마지막 문장에
추세 전환 확인을 위해서 첫 번째는
대형 고래 매수가 지속적으로 가속이
돼야 되고 어 두 번째는 수익권 공급
비율이 55% 그러니까 수익을 보고
있는 사람들의 비중이 55% 이상은
회복이 돼야 지금 바닥을 확인할 수
있고 마지막으로 스테이블 아 세
번째로는 스테이블코인 시가 총액이 좀
상승을 해야 되고네 번째는 규 규제
명확성이 조금 더 확보가 돼야 된다.
그래서 클레트 액트 같은 것들이 좀
확보될 필요가 있다라고 말씀을 주셨고
당사에 이거 가격이나 뭐 매수 신호
같은 것도 코를 주시더라고요. 그니까
신기해서 한번 가져와 봤는데 마지막
줄은 어 심리 주수를 가격으로
환산했을 때 매수 구간 한 25 정도
심리 구간으로 봤을 때 한 5
6,000불 정도가 될 거 같고
사이클 바닥 정말 진짜 어 극단적인
상황까지 간다라고 했을 때
47,000불에서 5만 불 정도가 어
예상이 되기 때문에 실질 바닥이 한
5만 불 정도 금방에서 형성될 거
같다라고 예상을 주셨습니다. 그래서
많은 다수의 사람들이 같은 구간이나
같은 기간을 저점 포인트나 어 그리고
최바닥으로 보는 거는 저 그렇게
긍정적이다고 보지는 않습니다. 왜냐면
사람들은 항상 시장은 어 그거에 그
구간을 주지 않는다라고 저는 생각을
어 그렇게 믿고 있기 때문에
그런데요. 어쨌든 지금 어 그때 션
페러 관련된 제가 자료 말씀드리도
그랬고 48,000불어
52만2,000불이 정도를 항상
바닥으로 보고 있는 어 분석들이
많다.이 이 정도의 흐름으로만 그냥
보시면 될 거 같고 매수매도
추천보다는 그런 사이클들이 있었고
그래서 그런 구간에 다시 한번 하락이
나왔을 때는 아 그 정도 구간이 되면
유동성 소위자 다시 한번 돌 수 있는
상황이 형성이 됐겠다이 정도는 저희가
해석할 수 있을 것 같아서 어 말씀을
드렸고 밑에 차트 두 개는 보시면 될
거 같은데 손실권 비중이 과거
사이클에 어떻게 됐었나 이런 흐름을
말씀 주시고 있습니다. 그래서 어
지금 흐름으로 봤을 때는 어 거의
바닥권에 있는 위치에 있는 것을 어
좀 확인하실 수가 있을 것 같고요.
오른쪽에 비트코인 과거와 현재 상승장
비교를 해 주셨는데 어 지금 회색선이
현재 상승장입니다. 상승장을 보면이
등락폭이 굉장히 많이 완화가 되고
축소가 된 것을 확인하실 수가 있어서
이번에도 이렇게 완만하게 어 이번
그니까 이번에는 이렇게 완만하게
빠지고 끝나는지를 저희가 확인하면 될
거 같은데 현재까지 상황으로 봤을
때는 어 위로 올라가는 것도 좀
제한적으로 올라갔었고 하락폭도 한
50% 정도 선에서 마무리된다라고
하면 어 비트코인 시장이 한 단계 좀
달라졌다. 다른 양상으로 가고 있다는
점을 저희가 확신할 수 있을 것
같습니다. 이상입니다.
>> 그러네요. 오른쪽 아래 차트 보니까
요게 청록색이라고
해야 할까요? 이게 지금 최근의
추세인데 어 과거 상승장과 비교해
보면은 더 내려갔다 와야 되는데 이제
그렇지 않을지가 또 관전 포인트 중에
하나인 거 같습니다. 어 이게 쭉
얘기를 들어보고 제가 궁금한 점이
상상인 증권 김경태 위원님이 이렇게
자세하게 분석해 주셨는데
>> 어 주식 같은 경우에는이 증권
거래소가 있기 때문에
>> 매수 주체도가 얼마에 사고 얼마에
지금 보유하고 있고 손익은 대략 어떨
거 같고 뭐 런 통계치나 추정을 좀
해 볼 수 있는데 거의 이제 그렇게
자세하게 이렇게 자료를 분해해
주셨는데이
>> 가상화폐 비트코인 뭐 이더리움 이런
것 관련해서도 그런 데이터를 제공해
주는 기관이 이미 있나 봐요.
>> 네. 네. 온체인 분석이라고
하는데요. 결국에 이제 블록체인이기
때문에 모든 것이 블록 그
>> 블록체인 장부상에 투명하게 남을
수밖에 없습니다.
>> 그래서 이게 어느 지갑에서 어느
지갑으로 이동하는 거 코인베이스
거래소 추정 지갑들이 있고요. 그리고
뭐 블랙록 추정 지갑들이 있기 때문에
이런 거를 추적하면서 아, ETF가
얼마나 들어왔구나.
거래같은 것들거래
그거에서 그거 마나는지 이런 것들은
>> 꽤 많이 올라와서 지금 온체인 분석이
어 퀄리티가 좋아졌다라고 생각합니다.
>> 저희와 같은 일반인들에게도 원하면
언제든 볼 수 있는
>> 대부분 유료라서요?
>> 아 유료지만 접근은 되는 네네.
그래서 접근돼서 이렇게 그
연구원인들께서 주시면 오히려 퀄리티
좋은 자리들 연구원인들 통해서 볼 수
있습니다.
>> 감사합니다.
>> 네. 저는 오늘 비트코인도
비트코인이지만 이제 주식 시장에
관련된 근무을 하는 사람 보니까 우리
어 솔트 부장님께 무언가 힘이
느껴지는 듬직하고 어 든든한 창민
프로라는 칭찬을 받은 창민
프로력주임이
맨 처음 모두에 트럼프가 이렇게
미사일 쏘고 다시 전쟁할 것처럼 해도
유가에 미치는 영향은 극히 제한적일
것 같다고
>> 딱 못을 받고 시작했는데 우리 창민%
프로 생각은 은 듬직한 참으로
저도
제한적이라고 생각합니다.
>> 음.
>> 강하게 영향을 줄 것 같진 않고 지금
당장은 좀 음료가 강해서 이렇게
민감하게 반응하고 있지만
>> 음
>> 점차가 완화될 것으로음
>> 우리
>> 미국 주식 시장과이 분석 투자를
열심히 배우고 있는 사수 최호
부사장들과 상이 된 멘트입니까? 어
일부분 상이 됐어. 아 유가 물어보면
크게 영향 결론 내자 그랬어요.
>> 그렇게까진 대화가 오가지 않았고요.
>> 네. 오늘 시장이 좀 어 우울하게 좀
시작할 것 같아서 어 잠깐 농담을 좀
해 봤는데요. 저희 1부에서도 좀
도움을 받으셨길 바라고 2부에서 이제
부사장님 그리고 정님 어 다른 분들께
자세한 또 내용 그리고 그 함의를
배우시면서 시장과 별개로 마음에 좀
평안을 찾으시는 체슬리 방송이 되기를
바랍니다. 1부 여기서 마치도록
하겠습니다. 잠시 후 2부에서 또
뵙겠습니다. 부해주신 처미턴 여러분
감사드립니다. 입니다.
เฮ
안녕하세요. 행복한 투자의 여정을
체슬리 투자 전문과 함께 체슬리 모닝
브리프 오늘 7월 8일 수요일 2부
순서 시작하도록 하겠습니다.
아 밖에는 비가 촉촉
내리고 있고 주식 시장도 예 비가 좀
내리고 있습니다. 그죠? 예,
그렇습니다.
>> 네. 악마철로 들었었어요.
>> 예.
비유가 적절하신 거 같은데요. 어제
미국 주요 지수 보시면은 다오 SNP
500 나스 로세리천 필반 지수 어
전부 하락을 했고 필반 지수가 어제
우리나라도 그랬지만 삼성전자 실적
발표를 기점으로
그리고 우리나라 반도체도 많이 빠졌고
어 미국 반도체도 어 좀 많이
빠지면서 최근 5일간 낙폭이 한
10% 정도 어 기록을 했고요.
101%를 찍었다가 지금 73.7%
7% 필반 지수 기준으로 상승해 있는
상황입니다.
약복 보면은 기 기본적으로 한
20에서 30% 정도 개별 종목으로
어 기준으로 이제 하락을 했는데 지금
시장 상황을 조금 점검을 해 보면은
아 항상 이렇게 좀 시장이 좀 안
좋고 좀 공포스러울 때 피어인 그리드
인덱스를 보게 되는데
피어인 그리드 인덱스는 오히려 어
극단적인 공포까지 갔다가
좀 올라와서 그냥 공포 구간으로
접어들었습니다. 그것도 이제 어
중립에 가까운 공포 구간으로
접어들었는데
가만히 생각해 보면 그 극단적
공포까지 갔을 때 쏠리면상이 가장
강했고요. 그 극단 그 쏠리면 현상이
좀 완화되고 어 반도체가 좀 빠지고
다른 가우 종목이나 SP 500이나
구경제 주식들이 좀 올라가면서 그런
솔립 현상들이 완화되는 모습들이
최근에 관찰되고 있는데 그러면서
피어인 그리드 인덱스도 어 조금 그
극단 공포에서 그냥 공포 쪽으로 어
공포 심리 자체 지수 자체로
살펴보면은 좀 낮아진 그런
상황입니다. 옆에 그 SP
500만으로 보면은 최근에
한 6월 말 정도의 어 극단점 공포를
기록을 했다가 SP 500은 오히려
어 올랐습니다.
6월 26일 기준으로 2.6% 정
2.0% 정도 어 상승을 했는데
이거는 반도체 섹터로의
극단적 쏠림이 완화되면서 섹터
확산하고 순환매에 따른 결과로
보여지고요. 밑에 SP 500하고
다우지수의 흐름을 보면은 최근에 어제
조금 조정을 받긴 했지만 어 우상향
추세를 어 단기적으로 기록을 하고
있고요. 쉬웠던 빅테크 종목들이 어
조금씩 올라오면서 SP 500에
긍정적 영향을 주었고 다우지수 또한
금융이라든지 헬스케어 이런 부분들이
긍정적 영향을 미치면서 어 신고가
부분에서 거래가 되고 있습니다. 반면
필반 지수는 어 전혀 다른 모습을 어
나타내고 있고 어이 이전에 기록했던
고점 대비로는
지금 한 15.9% % 한 16%
정도 하락을 했는데 어이 하락에
빌미가 됐던 것을 좀 정리를 해
보면은 어 메타발 잉여 인프라로 인한
케펙스 감소 우려하고 그리고 삼성전자
실적 발표 세론 그리고 일부 그
블룸버그나 UBS나 이런 쪽에서 그
나오는 내용들을 보면은 어
SK하이넥스 ADR 상장이 7월
10일 날 있는데 글로벌 투자자들이
들이 우리나라에서 SK 하이닉스를
팔고
뉴욕에 상장되는 어 ADR를 사기
위해서 이런 수급적인 이동이
있었다라고 얘기하는음 기사들도
있습니다. 그리고 때맞춰서 어떻게
이렇게 좀 한 번에 악재가 타시는지
모르겠는데 어제 유가 상승하고 금리
상승도 있었는데 아 금리가 4.5%를
어 넘어서 4.5%까지 5%까지
올라갔고요. 어 유가 자체도 어 5%
정도 어 상승을 한 상황입니다.
그래서 결과적으로 보면은
솔림이 계속해서 어 완화되는 과정에서
어 로테이션이나 섹터 확산이
이루어졌고 어 때마침 또 육가도
상승하고 금리도 상승하면서 어 필반
지수의 하락폭이 어 커졌고 어 반면에
그 반대 쪽에 있는 빅테크라든지 어
다우지스라든지
그간 시장에서 상당히 소호됐던
소프트웨어 ETF인
IGB 같은 경우도 어 최근에 좀
상승을 하고 있는 거 같습니다.
그래서 그 많이 빠지고 있는 지금
올해 그 필반 지수 어 조정
사례를 좀 보면은
지금 필반 지수의 그 지수 자체는
12,300 정도를 가르키고 있는데이
수준이 언제 수준이냐면 6월 5일 날
기록했던 12,220이라고
비슷합니다. 그래서 한 달 동안
올랐던 거 어 며칠 동안 다 그
반납한 상황이고 지수는 6월 초에
기록했던 레벨로 어 회기했다고 보시면
될 거 같고 전체적으로 필반 지수 내
어 좀 조금 조정을 받을 때는음
일부 차별화 포인트가 있는 종목들
같은 경우 어 덜 빠지고 뭐 더
빠지고 하는 또는 오르기도 하는 그런
상황이 연출이 되기도 했는데 아,
지금은 전반적으로
밑에 보시면은 어, 그 주요 종목
쪽에 어, 전고점 대비 10에서
30% 내외 전부 다 하락을 하고
있는데 어 상승률이 특히 높았던
메모리, 마이콘 테크놀로지나 장비,
램리서치나 어플라이드 머티리얼,
그리고 CPU 쪽에서 많이 올랐던
인텔이나 ARM 그리고 네트워킹
쪽에서도 계속해서 어, 폭발적인
상승세를 보여 보여주었던 어 마블
에스타랩 이런 것들이 전반적으로
하락을 하고 있습니다. 그래서 그
많이 올랐던 종목들이 최근에 이러저한
빌미로 인해서 10%에서 한 30%
내외에 어 하락을 하고 있다고 어
보시면 될 거 같습니다.
그래서 밸류에이션 쪽을 좀
살펴보면요. 한때 필반 지수 28배
한 29배까지 갔다가 아 최근
하락으로 인해서 22.900까지
900까지 좀 내려왔고 어 16%
정도 어 하락을 했는데 그 EPS
상향 조정이 마이크론을 비롯해서
최근에 좀 이루어졌기 때문에 어 지수
그 그 고점 대비 아 16%
하락했음에도 불구하고 어 PR은 더
좀 낮아진 어 그런 상황입니다. 20
2.9배에 거래되고 있고요. 어,
대표 종목이라고 할 수 있는 메모리
대표 종목이라고 할 수 있는 마이크론
같은 경우 6.7배에 거래되고 있고
어 고점 대비 22.7%가
어 하락을 했습니다.
국내 종목 중에서 삼성전자 같은
경우는 현재 아 19.9%가
고점 대비 하락을 했고요. 그리고
PR은 5.2배 거래되고 있고 SK
하이닉스도 어 고점 대비 26.8%
8% 하락한 가운데 PR은 5.5배에
거래가 되고 있습니다. 아, 그래서이
반도체 섹터의 그 전반적인 어,
매도세가 어, 나타나고 있다고 보시면
될 거 같고 정도의 차이는 있겠지만
어, 많이 오른 종목들로
급격한
차익 매물 또는 경계 매물이 출해되고
있다고 보시면 될 것 같습니다.
그래서 향후에 어떤 점을 보고 가야
하느냐. 음. 그리고이 섹터
로테이션이나 섹터 확산 이런 부분들의
반전 가능성이 어떤 것 어떤 것을
계기로 있을 것이냐라고 좀 생각을
해봤는데
일단은 좀 금리 레벨인 거 같아요.
굉장히 그 당연한 일 말일 수도
있는데 어 최근에 필반 지수가 조정을
받았던
특히 이제 조정을 뭐 5%에서 10%
내외 이렇게 받았던 구간을 살펴보면은
특히 금리가 급등하던 구간에서 조정을
받았는데이
흰색이 이제 필반 지수고 파란색이
미국제 10년물인데 미국제 10년물이
이렇게 튀었던 거를 그 동그라미로
표시를 했는데
여제없이 필반 지수가 뭐 정도의
차이는 있지만 작게든 깊게든 어
조정을 세게 받은 사례들이 있는데
이번에도이
전에 뭐 메타발 이슈라든지
뭐 케펙스에 대한 우려 뭐 이런
것들이 있긴 했지만 일단 이번에 그
또 하락에 어 결정적인 빌미가 된
것이 어 금리인 거 같고요. 그런
차원에서 금리가 좀 안정이 돼야지만
어 전반적인 킬반지수의
어 반등이 좀 있지 않을까라고 생각을
하고 있고 아 또 하나 이제 최근에
메타발 이슈로 인해서
논란이 되었던 어 케펙스 2추인데 어
이거는 시간은 좀 기다려야 됩니다.
그 7월 말 정도에 시작해서 어
하이퍼스케일러들의 실적이 발표가 되고
어 실적이 발표되면서 캠텍스
가이던스를 줄 텐데 아직까지 저희가
계속해서 그 시장에서 어 그 추정하고
있는 어 케펙스 추위의 변화를
살펴봤을 때 어 의미 있는 상향이나
하향 조정은 없다고 보시면 될 거
같고 26년 케펙스는 는
현재 어 758빌리년
정도로 어 예상이 되고 있고 어이
수치는 어 전에 한 어 3월 말 4월
초 어 기준 대비해서는 전반적으로
연간 기준으로 어 올라간 상황이고 어
최근에 어 6월 말에 어 발표된
JP모건의 케펙스
추위를 추위가 아직까지는 계속해서
에서 어 이어지고 있는 그런
상황입니다. 그래서이 부분이 어
하이퍼스케일러들이
그 얼마나 조정해서 어 그 발표가
되느냐라고
어 발표가 되느냐에 따라서 반등
여부가 좀 결정이 되지 않을까
싶고요. 아직까지는 그렇게 어
케펙스를 줄일 만한 의미 있는
시그널을 찾지는 못했는데 어 그거에
이제 하나의
증거로 아마존이 어제 또 어 채권
발행을 했는데 어 채권 발행을 통해서
최소 22 25빌년 달러에 달하는
자금 조달을 하기로 했습니다.
그 공시 사이트에도 어 공시를
했고요.
나오는 내용들을 보면은 미국체
대비해서 1.4% 포인트 높은
수준으로 발행을 한다고 하고 수요는
67빌리언 달러 정도가 몰렸다고
합니다. 어 조달 목적은 AI 인프라
확대고 그래서 수요 투자자들의 수요에
따라서 채권 발행 규모는 25빌년
달러보다 더 어 커질 수 있을
것이라고 어 내용이 나오고 있고요.
이런 것들로 봐서 케펙스 투자에 대한
의미 있는 어 축소라든지 이런 것들이
아직 감지되고 있지 않습니다.
그리고
관련해서 어 펭귄 솔루션이라는 시총
3.18빌리언 달러 정도 되는 어
회사가 오늘 장 끝나고 어 실적
발표를 했는데요. 시간에 6.3%가
%가 상승을 하고 있습니다. 어이
회사는 기업하고 클라우드 고객한테
고성능 컴퓨팅 인프라를 설계, 구축,
운영하는
아 회사고 또 서버 네트워크용
메모리를
메모리 모듈하고 스토리지 판매했는데
한마디로 메모리나 스토리지 가져다가
조립해서 어 엔터프라이즈 쪽으로 어
넘기는 회사라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다. 어, 매출이
478.7밀리언 7밀리언 달러가
나왔고 Yi로
40 8%가 증가를 했습니다. 통합
메모리 쪽에서 특히음 AI 출론용
메모리 모드의 모듈 이런 쪽에서
111%가 YY 어 증가를 했고요.
어 컨센스 227년
달러를 상의한 275밀러를
기록을 했습니다. 그리고 어드벤스
컴퓨팅 쪽에서는 비하이퍼스케일러 AI
인프라 쏘린 신규 쏘린 쪽이나 신규
클라우드 쪽인데 이쪽은 4% 정도
YY로 증가를 했고요. 그리고 LED
쪽도 있는데 이쪽은
66밀리언으로
어 그렇게 전체
그 매출 중에서 차지하는 비중은 어
높진 않습니다. 조정 영업 이익은
64.4밀러로 4년 달러로 YY로
67% 정도가 들었고요. 조정 영업
이익률은 13.4%가
나왔습니다. 전년 동기는 11.9%로
전년 동기보다는
좀 잘 나온 편이고요.
그리고
조정 EPS 같은 경우는 Yi로 어
79% 상승한 0.84달러가 8달러가
나왔습니다.이
이 기업을 굳이 보려고 한 거는
어쨌든 메모리 관련된 어 사업을 하고
있고 어 전 메모리 비용이 비싸짐에
따라서 어 전방에 어 수요처나
고객이 어떤 저항을 느끼고 있는지
그리고 그 수요는 경고한지 한번
보려고 했는데 어 26년 어 전체
연간 가이던스를 어 직전 가이던스보다
어 훨씬 높혔습니다. 직전에는 매출
성장률이 12%에서 플러스 마이너스
5%로 제시를 했었는데 이번에는
22%에서 어 플러스 마스 2%로
제시를 해서 어 크게 가이던스를
높혔고요. 그리고 조정 E패스 같은
경우도 2.6달러 수준으로 제시가
됐는데 아 직전 가이던스가
2.15달러 어 수준이었습니다.
그래서 연간 가이던스가
상형 조정됐다 이렇게 보시면 될 거
같고
코멘트는 좀 빠하긴 한데 보시면은 어
AI가 단순 지뢰 응답에서 스스로이를
수행하는 에이전틱 AI로 넘어가면서
더 큰 메모리 수요가 생기고 있다고
얘기를 하고 있고 어 그리고 AI
성능에 메모리가 어 핵심 병목으로
떠올랐고 회사는 메모리와 AI
인프라를 다루는 위치에서 처화하고
라고 코멘트했고 이번 메모리 수요는
AI가 만든 구조적 수요라서 과거
경기 등락에 따른 반등보다 오래 갈
것이라고 전망을 했습니다. 그리고
NBD 델과의 파트너십에서 인정받으며
생태견의 입질를 강화하고 있다고
얘기를 했습니다. 어 질문 중에서
하나 정도가 눈에 띄었는데 지난
분기의 메모리 가격 수급 환경 추세는
어떤가? 그리고 엔터프라이즈 고객이
가격 붙담을 느끼기 시작했나? 아,
이것에 대해 질문을 했는데 가격이
상승하고 있지만 수요가 계속 증가
중이고 수주 장고와 출화매출을 합친
전체 수요가 늘고 있다라고 답변을
했고요. 어, 주가는
주가하고 EPS는 계속해서 어,
계단식으로 최근에 들어서 어, 상향
조정이 되고 있고 어, 연초 이후로
한 200% 정도 어, 상승을
했습니다. PR은 현재 22.8배
8배 어 거래되고 있습니다. 중간에
메모리 가져다가 그 조립 또는
가공해서 어 엔터프라이즈 쪽으로
넘기는 사업을 하고 있기 때문에 맞은
자체가 그렇게 높진 않은데 전반적인
어떤 업항에 도움이 될까 싶어서 걸어
봤는데
코멘트나 어 질문 지의 응답에서는
대체로 그 이전에 메모리 사업자들이나
아니면은 스토리자들이 했던 코멘트하고
하고 비슷한 결의 코멘트가
나왔습니다. 이상입니다.
>> 이런 회사가 있는처럼 처음 알았네요.
>> 예. 저도 처음 알았습니다.
월요일에 문상무님이
얘기를 해서 좀 봤는데
>> 예.
>> 생긴 솔루션.
>> 시총은 좀 작다 그죠?
>> 예.
>> 시총은
4조 5천억.
우리나라 또는
하지만 그쪽 업항을 좀 알고 알 수
있으니까
>> 예
>> 그래서 그 대충 대리나 HP 이런
회사들이 또 그 메모리나 각종 그
원재료 수급을 해 가지고
엔터프라이즈항이나 하이퍼스케일러들로
넘기거든요. 아, 그런 회사하고 결이
비슷한 회사지 아닌가 아닌가
싶습니다.
>> 네.
>> 예.
이런 회사들 볼 때 조심해서 봐야
되는 거는
>> 어, 매출 증가는
원가에 연동해서
>> 매출
>> 구입하는 쪽에서 아, 메모리 가격
많이 비싸졌으니까
너네 제품 가격도 그거에 연동해서 좀
올려 줄게. 예, 맞습니다.
>> 요럴 수가 있고.
>> 어, 그렇게 되면 실제로 영업 익률
자체가 이렇게 별로 안 올라가요.
>> 예, 그렇습니다.
>> 그리고
또 그럴 수가 있죠. 이런 걸
바단에서
이제 수요가 계속 늘어날 걸 반영해서
미리 메모리라든지 이런 걸 이제
확보를 해 놨는데 메모리 가격이
급등하다 보니까
약간
여타에 2차전지 같은 경우에 밑이
계속 올라가면 그죠. 약간 메탈 개인
같은 거 얻을 수 있나? 미리 산놨던
원재료 가격이 올라가면서
거기에서 이제 마진이 또 높아지는
현상 이런게 나올 수도 있는
일단 Q&A에서는 앞단의 수요는
여전히 좀 경고하다.
>> 예. 그런 얘기도 해줬다 그죠?
>> 그렇습니다.
>> 네.
오히려 이런 회사들이 가격이 올라갔을
때 어 앞단의 수요에서
가격 저항을 느끼는지 보는 걸 오히려
더 민감하게 알 수 있는 회사고
>> 예
>> 가격이 상상하고 있지만 수요가 계속
증가 중이고 장고와 출화 매출의 합체
전체 수요가 늘고 있다라고 긍정적인
코멘트를 했었습니다.
자, 아마존이 채권을 또 발행을
했네요. 보니까.
>> 예, 그렇습니다.
>> 대충 스프레드가 한 1.4% 포인트.
지난번에 엔비디아가
0점 몇 %로 기억한 1% 내로 좀
기억하는데 요거보다 좀 낮았었던 거
같습니다.
>> 구글도에서 보고
>> 예, 그렇습니다. 구글은 그 유럽에도
했었고 만기가 꽤 긴 채권들을 좀
했었습니다.
그리고 아까 금리 말씀해 주셨는데
일단 10년물 국제 금리가
>> 네
>> 아요 부분이 좀
하향 추세로 내려와야 되는데 다시
4.5호까지 올라가면서이
부분이 신앙에 아무래도 또 영향을
주고
>> 예
>> 지난번에도 말씀드렸지만 이게 그냥
온탕 열탕 온도라고 보시면 되는데
이게 45.5° 모도 그렇게
생각하시면 됩니다. 그러면
아뜨거하면서
뛰어 튀어나오게 되는 그런
상황이다라고 보시면 되고 다행히
호르몬즈 회협에 대한 이후에 지금
나오는 조치들 보면
어 뭐 이런 정부에서는 뭐 일단
아니다 뭐 이렇게 얘기하는데 거기 뭐
혁명 준비대
>> 서로 따로 넓고 있다 보니까
>> 또 그런
마찰이 또 일어나는 거 같고요.
근데 고르무저 해협에 대한 노이저가
있었을 때마다 어떻게 보면 주식을
사는게 많았잖아.
>> 예. 그렇습니다.
>> 계속 그 피격 LNG선 피격 사건이
부분으로 인해서 어 미국 신당도
장중에 약간 영향을 받는 됐지만
언제나 말씀드리지만 중동에서
전쟁으로 인한 이슈로
국가가 빠질 때는 그럴 때는
바이언딥스 전략이 항상 맞았다. 그런
생각이 들기 때문에 6과 72불
반등이 들어왔었지만요 부분이
그렇게 장기적으로 노이저가 될 것
같지는 않습니다.
그동안이 좀 많이 올랐던 필반 지수가
그래도 막 필반 지수도 한 16%
빠졌고
>> 예
>> 그다음에 특히 메모리 쪽이 많이
올랐었는데
그 이격도 보면 너무 이제 많이
벌어져 있어 가지고
>> 예
>> 많이 어제 어젠가 우리 최부 사장님
말씀대로 너무 많이 올랐기 때문에
빠지
그런 모습이 좀 나오겠습니다.
>> 예.
한 달 전 수준으로 다 돌아가
가지고요.
>> 네. 가격 부담이 조금 많이 사라지긴
했는데 그 대략 보면 한 12%에서
한 15% 정도가 이전 패턴으로 봤을
때는 어 단기 바닥이기는 했습니다.
근데 어 최근에 나오는 그
리밸런싱이나
섹터 확산 그리고 순환 순환매 아
이런 것들에 대한 니즈나 코멘트 요런
부분들이 좀 강하다 보니까 그리고
우리가 확인해야 될 그 데이터가 월
말에 나오다 보니까 그 사이에 이제
공백이 조금 있을 것 같아요. 그래서
주가는 전반적으로는음
저가 매력은 조금 생겼지만 어 왔다
갔다 할 수 있는 상황에서 그
데이터를 보고 좀 확인하려는 심리가
강하지 않을까 아 요런 생각이 좀
들었습니다.음
알겠습니다.
어 국내 시장으로 넘어가서 어 국내
시장 보면서 어제 뭐 또 모건 스탠니
리포터 얘기도 해보고 하겠습니다.음
국내 시장으로 넘어가 보겠습니다.
어제 사우스코리아 ETF는
-4.51, 어제 코스피가 4.9
빠졌기 때문에 구행적으로 반영하는
서우스코리아 ETF EY는 4.5%
빠졌고 야간 선물도 2.6% 빠졌죠.
네. 빠졌습니다.
>> 네.
>> 이게 아무래도 오무제 해협에 대한
그런 부분을 또 방향을 좀 하는 거
같은데
국내 시장 동약 한번 쭉 훑어
보겠습니다.
>> 네. 어제 코스피 지수 약 5% 가량
크게 하락으로 마감을 했었고요. 어제
장주한테 8% 이상 하락하면서 서킷
브레이커도 또 걸리기도 했었습니다.
코스닥 시장은 좀 아쉬운
모습이었는데요.
어 좀 강했었을 때 2% 이상의
상승률을 기록을 하다가 코스피가 좀
워낙 강하게 밀리다 보니 코스닥
시장에도 영향을 준 거 같고요.
수급적으로 봐 주시면 개인 투사자가
전일장에 3조 이상 매도
매수했습니다. 그러면 외인들의 매도는
지속적으로 나오고 있는데 어 3조
가까이 매도 물량이 나왔었고요.
기관에서는 크게 움직임은 없었습니다.
외인 선물은 8,800가량
순매수가 유입이 되긴 했습니다.
투자자별 매매 동향을 보면 어제
외국인 투자자는 삼성전기, LG노텍,
대덕 전자, 네이버, 현대 로템,
원익 IPS 등을 매수를 했었고요.
매도 쪽에는 삼성전자 SK닉스 어
조단위의 매도가 나왔습니다. 그
외에는 하나 오션, KB금융,
현대차, 기아, 두산 에너빌리티 등을
매도를 했었고요. 기간 매수에는
하이브, 그리고 SO1, KB금융,
신한 지주, AP, 삼양식품,
파마 리서치 등을 매수를 하면서 어
기관에서는 뭐 엔터나 그리고 화장품,
피부 미용 등을 매수하면서 좀 소비
쪽으로의 수납매가 전일에 좀 돌았던
거 같습니다. 어, 기간 매도에는
삼성전자, 삼성전기, SK 수퀘어,
LG 이노텍 등을 매도를 했었고요.
LG 에너지 솔루션도 매도를 했는데
어제 LG 엔솔도 실적이
나왔었거든요. 근데 어닝 쇼크를
기록을 하면서 어 주가가 좀 약했던
모습입니다.
아래 52주 신고가 종목은 총네
종목이었는데요. 최근에 은행주들이
계속 좀 강한 거 같습니다. KB
금융 그리고 신한지 KB 발행 인프라
등이 신고가의 이름을 올렸습니다.
네. 지금 52주 신고가의 KB금융
신한 지주 52주 신고가에 있다라는게
되게 중요한 의미이거든요.
시장이 이제 끝난 거 아닌가
그런 생각을 하시는 분들도 많으실
건데 그러면 KB 금융 신한 지부
이런 주식이 신고가가 나면 안 돼요.
네. 1,500원이 넘는 환율 보면서
계속 어 뭔가이 부정적인
그런 위험이 있다. 뭐 이런 얘기
하시는 분들도 가끔씩 있는데 그러려면
우리나라 금융주가 저렇게 신고가가
남아 돼요. 그래서 어 시장이 큰
우리가 모르는 시스템 리스크가 있거나
뭐 그러지 말.
자, 그러면 주요 종목들 동향 한번
쭉 보겠습니다.
>> 네. 반도체 섹터 먼저 살펴보면 어제
전자의 주가나 SK닉스의 주가가
상당히 부진했는데요. 전자에 나쁘지
않으실 호실적에도 불구하고 주가는
상당히 약했었습니다. 여러 가지
이슈가 있었는데 모스탠니에서
메모리 반도체를 좀 줄이고
하이퍼스케일러 쪽 비중을 늘려야
된다. 뭐 이런 이야기를 했고요. 뭐
근거로는 어 실적 추정치 사용
조정되는 폭이 이제 둔화되는 시기에
접어들었다라는 의견을 제시하면서
메모리에 대한 의견을 좀 보수적으로
스탠스를 좀 바꾼 거 같은데요. 뭐
그런 영향도 일부 주가에 미치지
않았나라는 생각이 들고 또 오늘
보니까
어 국내 증권사에서도 키움 증권이었나
쪽에서 삼성원자 목표 주가를 하향
조정하더라고요. 근데 그 근거도 모건
스탠리와 똑같습니다. EPS 사양
조정되는게 이제 하반기 가면서
둔화되기 때문에 목표주가 하향으로
내리는 리포트가 나왔는데 그
연구원님의
이전 리포트를 보니까 6월
말이더라고요. 근데 그때는 목표 주가
상향이었는데
>> 6월만
>> 네. 네. 그러니까
>> 일주일 만에
>> 나도 키움증권에서 얼마 전에 그
반도체 창조했던 걸로
>> 기억을 하는데
>> 일주일 만에 좀 톤을 바꿨는데 뭐네
뭐 목표 주가와의 괴리율 목표 주가와
현재 주가의 괴리율 차이 이런게
심해지다 보니
>> 뭐 영인 입장에서는 좀 내린게 아닌가
그런 생각이 들기는 합니다.
>> 아래 소부장 종목들도 최근에 좀
정신을 못 차리고 있는데요.
HPSP라든지 리노우어, 이오테크,
원익 IPS, 심텍, 두산테스나
솔브레인 뭐 다 약했는데
장비나 소재 기판할 거 없이 대체로
좀 약세 흐름입니다. 확실히이
메모리나 국내 반도체와 좀 디커플링
되는게 파크 시스템지거든요.
이상합니다. 이거 항상 그런데 오히려
메모리가 좋거나 다른 소부장이 좋을
땐 좀 얌전이 있거든요.
>> 맞아. 근데 또 쉬기 시작하니까
파크는 조금 최근에 주가도 좀 돌기
시작했고요. 다른 거 많이 빠져
있는데 원먼스 기준으로 -4.5%밖에
안 되거든요. 파크가 좀 이런 현상이
또 반복이 되고 있는 상황입니다.
>> 근데 연초 이후로 보니까 그렇게 많이
오른 건 아니네요. 보니까.
>> 네. 어 실적이 1본기 때 그렇게
좋지 않았던 거 같아요. 그래서 실적
영향도 뭐 있었던 거 같고 다른
기업들은
>> 모멘텀들이 상당히 지금 많은 상황인데
파크는 그런 쪽이랑은 좀 연결이 되어
있지 않기 때문에 상대적으로 좀
소해되어 있기는 합니다.
>> IT 섹터로 넘어가서 보면 삼성전기의
주가가 약 10% 가량 급락이
나왔습니다. 뭐 업항 자체는 너무나
좋은데 역시나 메모리가 꺾이다 보니
같이 올랐던 전기의 주가도 최근에
낙폭은 좀 커지고 있는 상황이고요.
LG 이노텍도 4.8% 하락
마감하면서 뭐 깊판 이쪽 다 안
좋았던 거 같습니다. 어제 플랫폼
섹터는 시장 대비로는 괜찮은
흐름이었고요. 리케이 지수 2%대
약세 흐름을 보였는데 여기도 반도체나
IT 종목이 상당히 안 좋았습니다.
도쿄 일렉트론 4% 하락했고요.
MCC하고 있는 무라타가 10% 급락
했고 디스코도 7.8,
이비덴이 7% 가량 하락
마감했습니다. 이비덴이 90배의
멀티플까지 올라갔었고요. 무라타가
55배까지 올라갔었는데 밸류에이션이
최근 주가 하락 영향이 좀 내려오고
있는 상황이다라고
볼 수 있을 거 같고요. 자동차
섹터는 하루 좀 올라가더니 어제 바로
반락했습니다. 현대차가 4.5,
기아도 4%대의 낙폭을 보였고요.
소비제 섹터가 상당히 좋았는데 생건
아몰의 대형 화장품 다 좋았고 아래
OEM ODM 업체들도 한 2%대
올라줬고요. 피우 미용 계기도
좋았습니다. 클래시스가 5%
파마리서치가 8% 가량 크게 상승세를
기록을 하면서 시장 대비 큰
아웃퍼폼을 보여줬고
APR도 8%가 급등했습니다. 그리고
원택은 보합 정도 마감했고요. 아래
음식 섹터도 좋은 흐름이었는데요.
농심 3%형식품이
11% 급등세를 보였습니다.
KTNG도 6% 오르면서 뭐 필수
소비제 음식료, 화장품, 피부 미용
기기 대체로 좋은 흐름이었고요.
조선 철감미 기타 섹터 봐 주시면
어제 뭐 조선주들은 안 좋을 수밖에
없었는데 하나 우선이 크게
하락했습니다. 22%
급락세를 보였고요. 현대 중업이
5.3 하나 엔진이 7.6
하락했습니다. 하나행진는 뭐 한
15% 가까이 빠지기도 했었는데요.
하나행진는 이번 하나 오션의 캐나다
잠수함수주
실패에 영향을 받는 기업은 아닌데
어제 주가가 좀 과도하게 빠지다 보니
그래도 밑골이 달고 올라오는 모습은
긍정적이었던 거 같습니다.
아래 철강이나 화학 섹터 대체로
부진했고요.
어 방산주 쪽 흐름 보면 하나 여로가
3% 하락했고 넥선이 2% 현대 로템
5% 정도 빠졌습니다.데 어제 장중한
때 더 크게 방산주들도 밀렸었거든요.
이번에 하나 오션이 캐나다 잠수하면서
떨어진 이유가 결국에 캐나다와 나토
동맹국 간의 관계 때문일 것이다라는
이야기들도 많이 나왔는데 지금 국내
방산업체들도 나토 국가들에게
유럽적으로의 납품하려는 노력들이 많이
이루어지고 있잖아요. 그런 부분에 좀
영향이 있을 수도 있다라는
생각을 한 투자들이 있었던 건지 장
초에는 굉장히 세게 밀렸었습니다.
그리고 바이오 섹터는 나쁘지
않았습니다. 삼성 바이오나 에피스
홀딩스 대체로 상승 마감하는 흐름이
나왔고요. 코스닥 시장에서 코스닥
바이오가 어제 오전장인 또 굉장히
강하기도 했었는데 좀 밀리면서 끝나긴
했습니다. 뭐 알테오젠, ABL
바이오, DND 파막등이 상승하는
모습이었고요.
52주 신고가에서 봤다시피 KB
금융이 상승 마감했었고
어 키움 증권은 최근 강세 흐름을
뒤로 하고 약세 전환했습니다. 엔터
쪽이 또 상당히 좋았습니다. 하이브가
약 8% 올랐고요. SM이 6% 가량
상승 마감 YG도 1.5%
올랐습니다. 변환기 쪽도 AI 밸류
체인이 약하다 보니 동반에서 내려오는
흐름이고요. 현대 인맥이나 효성 중고
30배 2만으로 떨어졌습니다. 그래서
여태까지 한 3, 4년 3년 간의
흐름을 보면 30배 미만에서는
그래도 매수 찬스로 항상 활용을 할
수 있었던 거 같긴 한데네 30배
미만으로 떨어졌습니다.네
예,
얼마 전만 하더라도요 반도체 및
소부장 요쪽 섹터 말고는 다른 섹터가
정말 처참하게 팔했었는데
언젠가 소비제 쪽이 희밋희ياه하게
약간 연분홍 스빛이 나면서 어,
요쪽이 이제 좀 살아나는 거 같다.
그런 느낌이 들다고 지난주인 거 같지
얘기했던 거 같아.
미국 시장도 마찬가지예요. 미국
시장도 소비자들이
쓸
>> 쓸 쓸 거니다. 이렇게 반등이
들어가고 XV 같은 바이오 인덱스가
신고가를 내고요.
시장의 색깔이 약간 좀 변하는듯한
예, 그런 모습이 나오고 있습니다.
그게 일시적인 현상인 건지
추세의 어떤 주도주의 변화가 일어나는
건지 그 부분을 좀 더 지켜보면서
해야 되겠지만음
왔다 갔다 하면서 다 올라갈 거
같고요. 음.
자, 어, 리포트 가져오셨는데 어제
삼성전자 이제 장정 실적에 관한 어리
내용으로 아, 우리 KB 김동원
센터장님.
>> 네.
>> 예. 리포트 나왔네요.
>> 과격한 주가 반응에 내동 하지 말자.
네. 네. 음,
>> 제목이 좀 셌었는데요.
>> 어, 일단 어제 실적은 간단하게
말씀을 드렸었기 때문에 좀 스킵을
하고 어, 동사에 대한 투자회견
매수, 타겟 프라이스 55만 원
그대로 유지를 했다고 합니다. 지금
고점 대비 20% 이상 하락하면서
현재 주가 대비 괴리도가 좀 크긴
한데 견조한 업판과 기업 경쟁력,
낮은 밸류에이션 배수를 고려해 봤을
때 목표가를 하향할 상황은 아니라는
의견입니다. 현재 주가 기준 동사의
26년 예상 멀티플 및 PB 배수는
각각 6.
2.6배 수준이라고 하고요. 동사의
어 2분기 잠정 실적은 매출 171조
정도 나왔고 2익이 정도 나왔는데 어
시장 기대치 및 당사 추정치 모두
상회하는 숫자였다라고 합니다. 부음별
영업익은 DS 쪽이 86조
정도로 보는 거 같고요. 여기에는
메모리가 105조원, 파운드리가 1조
적자 그리고 충단금 등이 반영된
숫자라고 합니다. 그리고 DX 부분
2.1조 SDC가 0.7 7 하만
쪽이 0.6조원 정도로 각각 추정이
된다라고 하고요. 메모리 사업의 세부
지표는 디램 빅크로스가 +4%
ASP가 36%
증가를 기록하면서 영업 이익이
65.6조
나온 것으로 추정을 했고요. 랜드 쪽
빅크로스는 3% ASP는 54%
증가하면서 랜드 쪽은 영업이
21.4조 4조 나온 것으로 추정을
했습니다. 어 디램 추라는과 가격이
예상을 하회했는데 HBM 추화가
늘어난 것으로 보인다라고 하고요.
HBM 32의 경우 작년 협상 가격
기반으로 거래가 되기 때문이라고
합니다. 실적 호조에도 불구하고 가격
상승률의 둔화에 대한 우려가 주가
약세로 반영되고 있는 것으로
보여진다고 하고요. 그러나 27년에도
ASP 상승은 지속될 것으로 보고
있습니다. Hm 4 가격은 YY 두
배에서 세배 상승할 가능성이 높다라고
하고요. H1 공급 확대로 인한
컨벤셔널 공급 여력 제한 기조나 어
디 가격 상승 구간은 여전히 좀
이어질 것이다. 긍정적인 톤으로
얘기를 했고 3분기에도 디램이나
랜드가 공이 QQ 10% 정도의 어
가격 인상 이루실 것으로 예상을
했고요. 각플 + 5% 수준의 비꾸로
수출화가 되면서 3분기 전사 실적은
매출액 2011조, 영업 이익
120조 정도로 추정을 했습니다.
26년 27년 예상 영업 이익도 각각
400조 그리고 570조 정도 소폭
상향 조정을 했다라고 하고요. 올해
뭐 811% 증가했고 내년에 되면 한
45%
증가할 것으로 추정을 했습니다.
24년에서 26년 프리캐시플로우의
프리캐시플로우 50% 주조하는 이행시
현 주가 기준 배당 수익률은 보통주
최대 6% 우선주 10%를 조화할
것으로 보여지고요. 동산은 임직원
보상 목적의 자사주 25조원 규모를
보유하고 있다라고 합니다. 지급해야
할 성가급 규모를 고려해 보면 추가
매입이 불가피한 상황이라고 하고요.
주가도 1분기의 자사주 매입 가격에
인접한 상황이다. 그리고 참고할 것은
동사의 실적 컴콜은 7월 30일에
10시 오전에 진행될 예정이라고
합니다.
이게 본 본실적 발표 하는 거죠.
>> 7월 30 날이네.
>> 지난번에는 하이닉스랑 전자랑 같은 날
했는데
하이닉스는 아직 저거 날짜는 안
정해졌어.
아직입니다.
>> 제가 잘해야지 했어요. 다시 한번
말씀해 주시겠어요?
>> 하이닉스 얘기만 하면 이게 하이빅스로
인수할까? 항상 이렇게 대답
>> 그러면 물어봐야 되겠네. 하이닉스
실적 발표는 언제야? 이렇게.
자, 그리고 밑에 표도 조금 나오고
있는데 그동안 계속 그 분리시하게
리포트를 내시고 했는데음
제목처럼 과격한 주가 반등에 내동하지
말고 오히려 QQ 그리고 제가 또
하나 궁금했었던게 이제이 비크로스인데
가격만 올라가는 건지 실제로 Q도
늘어나는 건지 그게 중요한 부분인데
>> 어 각각 5% 수준 전에 비스도
다음 분에 연상된다. 거기다가 가격은
15% 정도 올라가고 그런 얘기다.
그죠?
>> 혹시 문상문이 추가 코멘트 할 거
있습니까?
>> 예. 뭐 가격은 저희가 추적하다시피
다음 분기 3분기에 한 20% 전후
기름 기준으로 올라갈 것 같고요.내는
그거보다 조금 더 위로 올라갈 것
같습니다. 전망치들이 조금씩 더 최근
들어 올라오고 있는 모습 나오고 있고
빅크로스는 연간 기준으로 어 10%
후반대 정도 나오니까 분기 기준으로는
뭐한 4, 5% 정도가 평균값이라고
보시면 될 것 같습니다.
자, 그래서 다음 분기에 어 이익이
120조
매출은 200조.
제가 그래서 영업 이익률은 그러면
어떻게 되나? 매출 200조에 영업이
120조니까 영업 익률이 60%네.
이번이 영업 익률이 지금 얼마었죠?
>> 아 50%대 나왔습니다. 54%
정도.
>> 2 18 하면 50% 살짝 넘는다
그죠?
그러면 보통 우리가 영업 이익률이
꺾이지 않으면 이게 바가 꺾이는게
아니거든.
그러면 3q가이
요대로만 나오면
어떻게 보면
어 이번 조정을
받고 다시 반등이 들어가는 거
그거리만 예상을 할 수가 있죠.
계속 아마 증권사마다 코멘트들이 이제
계속 줄줄이 나올 거예요. 그죠?
>> 네.
>> 일단 고점 대비 지금 한 20%씩
빠졌습니다.
>> 예. 그렇습니다. 예.
>> 바로 앞전에 6월 달에 22, 3%
정도 딱 빠졌다고 들어갔고
>> 예. 그때도 어 지수도 그렇고
종목들도 한 그 정도 빠졌다가 반등은
들어갔었습니다.
>> 그리고 그동안에 우리나라이 설브레이크
걸리면 그다음 날에도 장태 양폭
나던데
>> 거의 90% 확률로 양봉이 나고이
거래일 때도 거의 대부분 상승하는
경우 같아. 그래서 오늘 시장이 되게
궁금해요.
그리고 또 우리 댓글창에 또 예리하신
분이 어 체슬리 인덱스이 조회수로
>> 음
>> 조회수 현재 참가하고 계시는 분이
2,명이 넘어야 찐바닥이다. 어
그렇게 얘기를 하셔 가지고 어
>> 하긴 지난번에도 그랬지 했는데 쓰하게
지금 1934년
>> 그러
>> 아 이거 2천 실시간 2천이 안
나오고 있어요. 그래서 찐바닥이
아닌가?
조금씩 올라가는데 1966.
>> 1966. 예. 빨리 지금 주변에
계시는 분들은 예. 빨리 지금 채슬리
TV 좀 들어와서 예. 바라고 얘기를
좀 해 주셔서
>> 이게 실시간 2천을 넘어야이
진바닥이 했는데 그죠? 체슬리 인덱스
굉장히 이게 제가 봐도 유 굉장히
유의미한
>> 그런 데이터더라고요.
>> 과연 2,000을 넘을지 기대가
됩니다. 다른 유튜브 채널 가셔
가지고 어 빨리 채슬리 TV로 오라
해 주셔야 그거는 장대 양봉이
가능하다죠.
아, 1986.
>> 아,
네. 거의
자 그러면 어 하이브 한번가 볼게요.
리포트 유한타 이흥 연구원의 리포트가
나왔습니다. 최근에요 반도체가 약간
주춤하니까예
>> 요쪽이 올라가는데
>> 이게 롱쇼 개념도 제가 지난번에
말씀드렸었는데 일단 펀더멘탈이
좋아져야 되는 거니까이 펀더멘탈은
어떻게 되는지 리포트 보면서 한번
체크해 보겠습니다. 2분기 실적이
이제 눈앞에 있기 때문에 관련 내용을
좀 간단하게 코멘트 해 줬는데요.
2분기는 확신의 실적 개선 구간
진입이다라는 제목입니다. 이분기 예상
매출로 1조 1,400억대 전망을
했고요. 그래서 YY로 62% 증가
전망입니다. 영업 이익은 1,500억
정도 나오면서 YY 126%
증가할 것으로 추정을 하고 있고요.
시장 기대치에 보합하는 호실적 시현이
나오지 않을까라는 전망입니다. BTS
월드투 응액행 및 MD 판매오 조세가
원활하게 이루어지고 있다라고 하고요.
IP 포트폴리오 전반에 고마진 앨본
판매 실적이 기존 추정치를 상회한
데에 따른 것이다.라는 코멘트를
했습니다. 그다음 앨범 쪽
이야기데요. 총 1번 판매량은
1,200만 장을 상의하는 수준으로
역대 최대 판매량까지는 못 미치지만
BTS양 글로벌 바이닐과 코르티스
머치 만든 고가 폼중 확대에 따른
ASP 상승으로 역대 최대 앨범
매출을 견인할 것으로 전망을
했습니다. 공연 쪽은 BTS 월드투어
실적이 본격 반영됨에 따라 역대 최대
실적 시현이 나올 것이다라는
전망이고요. 360도 개방형 공연 및
온라인 스트리밍까지 추가된 영향이
높아진 인세 부담을 상쇄할 것으로
기대된다라고 합니다. 그다음 MDA
및 라인선싱인데요. 우호적인 환율
효과가 지속되는 가운데 온 오프라인
투어 MD 판매 조세가 이루어졌다라고
하고 다변화된 기획 MD 제품은 역시
보수적인 제고 관리와 함께 추가적인
수익성 개선으로 이어졌을 것이다.
코멘트를 했습니다.
투자 매력도 상승 포인트가 하나 더
있다라고 하는데요. 팬덤
크로스링이라고 합니다. 올해 상반기
주가 납벌 키웠던 비오호적 수급
이슈와 지정학적 리스크 두 가지
요인이 조금씩 선해하는 가운데 이분기
호실정 및 저연차의 본격적인
터너라운드 진입 구간까지 감안을 해
보면 현재 역사적 밴드 하단에서의
투자 매력도는 매우 높다는
판단이고요. 또 지난 달매한 디지털
싱글 아이코닉 바이 미스테이클의 효과
흥행 효과에 주목할 필요가 있겠다라고
합니다. 신규 마케팅 투화 없이 팬덤
크로스링을 통해서 리세라미나 아일릿
캐치하이 세틴 모두에서 글로벌 인지도
확산이 뚜렷하게 나타났다라고 하고요.
팬덤 크로스링의 수익화 가능성을
보여준 초기 사례로 중장기 실적 개선
관점에서 밸루에이션 정상화 논리를
뒷받침하는 근거로 판단을 한다.
어,이 크로스 셀링이 사실 가장 잘
나타나는 회사가 SM이거든요. SM은
어, 여러이 함께 그 유닛도 해
가지고 콘서 그 공연도 하고 음원도
되고 했었는데 하이브는 사실 그런
쪽에서는 좀
움직임이 없었거든요. 근데 이번에
그런 움직임이 나타난 걸로 봐서는
이제 뭐 리세라핀 펜이 케차이 펜이
될 수도 있는 거고 캐차이 펜이
아일리 펜이 될 수도 있는 거고 뭐
이런 식으로 회사가 방향성을 좀
바꾸는 거 같습니다. 자 아래
실적자료를 보면요. 1분기가 어 숫자
자체는 어닝 쇼크였거든요.
1966억 적자였는데 한 2,억
정도가 주식보상 비용으로 그
임원들한테 나눠주는 네. 그쪽으로
나가면서 사실 그 부분을 제하고 보면
컨센데 대비한 20% 상회하는 실적을
1분기 때 발표하긴 했었거든요. 그
이제 2분기인데
어 2분기 실적 전망은 약
1,500억 정도로 영업 이익이
추정을 하고 있는 상황입니다. 그
3분기에도 한 1,500억 정도,
4분기 되면 1700억 전망이 되고
있습니다. 2분기 실적이 무엇보다
현재 중요한 상황인데 BTS가
콘서트를 돌고 있는 실적 그리고 앨범
판매 실적이 온기 반영되는 첫 분기가
이번 2분기거든요.
하이브의 주가가
거의 한 콘서트 첫 한국에서 콘서트
넷플릭스랑 같이 협업회산 콘서트
전날이 주가 고점을 찍고
>> 그 이후로 쭉 빠지다가 최근 한 3,
4거래일 정도 일주일 정도 이제
올라오고 있는 흐름인데 2분기 실적이
또 어떻게 나오느냐에 따라이 방향성이
정해질 것 같거든요. 만약에까 보니까
인세율이 너무나 높은 거 같다라는
코멘트가 나와 버리면 2, 3,
4분기 추정치가 다 꺾여 버릴
거거든요. 그래서 그 부분을
체크하는게 가장 중요하다라는 생각이
들고 근데 시장에서는 이미
22배 23배까지 밸루에이션이 빠졌다
지금 올라오고 있는 거기 때문에
최악을 가정한 밸류까지는 이미 한번
갔다 왔거든요. 그래서 그런 부분은
좀 참고해서 볼 만 봐야겠다라는
생각이 들고 오른쪽은 영업비익률 추위
전망인데요. 역시 이제 BTS가
돌아오다 보니 영업 이익률이 바닥을
찍고 올라가는 흐름 향후에 기대해
보자라는 전망이 깔려 있는 상황인 거
같습니다. 그래서 하이브 실적이 잘
나와야 SM이건 JP건 Y건 방향을
계속 이런 지금 올라가고 있는데
>> 하이브 실적이 가장 중요해 보이고
있는 상황인 거 같습니다. 사실 다른
기업들 업항이나 실적은 나쁘지
않거든요. 지난 1분기도 그렇고 내가
하이브가 빠지다 보니 뭐 다 같이
빠진 상황입니다.
하이브가 빠지다 보니 지금 빠진
따라기보다는
어 2년 전에도 24년도에
슈퍼 선거에해 플러스 올림픽 네.
>> 예. 그러면서 그때도 비슷한 주가
움직임을 다 같이 보였었고 그리고 다
같이 올랐고 최근에 또 다 같이
빠지고
또 언제 이제 반등이 들어가는가
보면이
짝수에 또 한 9월 10월 언저리부터
올라가기 시작해 가지고 내년 또 한
7월 달까지 올라가는 그런 패턴이 좀
반복되는 거 아닌가 싶고 스포티파이
보니까 뭐 비슷한 흐름이었다고 그죠?
고 그건데 궁금한게 여기 26년에서
27년 넘어갈 때 매출은 올해 매출이
4조 3,000원 이게 BTS 복기로
그때 광화문에서 했던게 3월 20
날이었나 뭐 그때 아까 말씀하신 대로
그때부터 빠지기 시작해 가지고 3 4
5 6 7 지금 5개월 동안 어 많이
빠졌어요. 그렇죠.
>> 네.
>> 예. 많이 빠졌는데 자 올해가 한
4조 3천억 정도 매출이 나오는데
내년에는 매출이 빠져요.
-9,억이네.
그래서 3조 9,억 정도로 한 4,억
정도 빠지는데 밑으로 쭉 내려가서
영업 이익을 보니까 올해 2,700억
영업 이익인데 내년에 4,987억
매출은 빠지는데 오히려 이익은 더 큰
폭으로 늘어나는 그래서 요게 이제 뭐
BTS가 가져가는 아무래도
>> 배분이
그 BTS 쪽 매출은 많이 나오는데
어 회사가 가져가는 혹시 좀 적을
수가 있고 근데 내년에는
어 매출은 주는데 그이 영업 이익이
큰 폭으로 증가해서
>> 내년 증가하는게 뭔가
>> 아이 부분은 아 아까 말씀드렸지만이
분기 실적 보면 1분기에 영업 이익
적자가 2,억이었습니다.
>> 그래서 올해 1분기에
>> 네. 네. 그래서 이걸 그냥 올해 그
26년 전 어 이익에다가
2,700억에 2,억을 도해 놓고
보면
>> 한 4,700억이기 때문에 내년에
소폭 증 이익 증가 정도로
>> 볼 수가 있는 거거든요.
>> 근데 전 사실이 부분이 조금
애매하다고 생각해서
>> 이제 엔터 세미할 때마다
연구원님들한테 한 물어봤거든요. 내년
이렇게 이익을 찍어 놓은 이유가
뭐냐?
큰 이유가 없다. 그냥 내년은 좀
불확실한데 그냥 일단 좀 계산해 놓은
거다. 내년 숫자는 그렇게 유미하게
보지 말아 달라 이렇게 하더라고요.
>> 음.
>> 예. 그래서 내년에 BTS의 활동이
어떻게 될지는 명확하지 않기 때문에
이게 단체 활동이 끝나고 개인 활동을
바로 할지
>> 아니면 쉬 버릴지
>> 이런 거는
>> 어 불확실합니다. 그래서 그 부분은
내년 실적은 좀 배제하고
>> 보는게 맞지 않나?
알겠습니다. 하인 내년 숫자가
좀 애매할 수도 있.
>> 네. 네. 맞습니다.
>> 또 내년에 혹시 또 새로운 아이들에서
어디가 뭐 또 빵 터질 때 그죠.
음. 알겠습니다.
레세라 পারে 아일리 캐차이.
>> 네.
>> 예. 여
아이돌 다 잘나 잘 나가긴 잘
나가요.
>> 다 여돌인데요.
>> 아 여돌.네 데 좀 타겟 시장이
다릅니다. 르세라핑은 완전 서구권
쪽으로 노리는 뭐 음원이나
퍼포먼스 그런 거를 많이 하고요.
아일릿의 경우는
굉장히 어린 걸로 알고 있거든요.
그래서 국내 일본 약간이 아시아권을
노리는 어 그룹이고 캐차이는 미국
현화 그룹입니다. 그래서 굉장히
캐차이가 잘하고 있는 상황이고 사실
셋다 잘하고는 있는데 르세라힘은 좀
대비한지 좀 됐거든요.
앨범 판매량이나 이런 부분에서 조금
저합니다. 근데 그 이유는 미국이
타계시면 앨범 판매량은 저조할 수밖에
없거든요. 아시아권 국가들이 앨범을
많이 사주 서구권은 공회원이나 직접
참여형 쪽으로 많이 가기 때문에 그런
부분은 아쉽지만 어쨌든 서구권의
노출도를 가져가고 있다는 노력은
긍정적인 거 같습니다.
알겠습니다.
자, 그리고 아까 어
설킷이 얘기를 했었는데 또 우리
호수님이 아주 또 중요한
헌터 데이터를 말씀을 해 주셨습니다.
-8% 이상 빠졌을 때는 어 90%
이상 확률은 반등이 들어갔는데 어
어제처럼 -4 5% 정도로 요렇게
올라왔을 때나 그다음날 종가도
마이너스였던 경우가 많다.
>> 감사합니다.
자, 우리나라 시장 예상
정확한 워딩을 다시 읽어 드리면 과거
설 발생 종가가 -8% 아래일 때는
다음날 종가는 상승했으나 -8%
초과시
그러니까 위에서 끝났을 때 다음날
나의 종가는 마이너스였다.
어제가 -4.91이었기 9일이었기
때문에 종카는 마이너스를 예상 이렇게
어 최근에 보면 저도 이래 강년을
다니거나 어디 이렇게 따로 얘기를 해
보면
>> 전부 사실 삼성전자 얘기가 제일
많았어요. 서 얘기가 제일 많았기
때문에
두 배짜리 레버리지도
많이 들어가 있었고
그래서 약간 반대 매매 또
>> 코 전체 시 그 신용 물량이 37조가
넘었는데
>> 코스닥에서 넣는게 아니라 코스피에서
넣죠.
>> 예.
그 코스피에서 넣은 것 중에 많은
부분이 또 전자 하이닉스로려 있어서
어떻게 보면 오늘 오전 중으로이 반대
매매가 좀 나올 수도 있겠다는 생각이
드네요.
>> 그래도 그 소통하는
>> 증권사 영업점들이 좀 있는데 반대
매매가 나올 걸 어 예상해서 담보
부족이 생기잖아요. 담보 부족을 알게
되니까 미리 이제 주식을 파는
수요들이 계속 나온다고 하더라고요.
어 벌써
>> 예 어제 또
>> 어제부터
>> 예 어제부터 나왔다고 합니다.
>> 그러니까 왜냐면
>> 오전 중에 영향을 좀 주예 왜냐하면
담보 구조 그걸 해결하지 않으면 그냥
무조건 반대 매매가 나가기 때문에
그거 맞기 전에
>> 미리 하나 놓는 수요들이 있다고
합니다.
최근에 들어오셔 가지고 어 주식을
새로 시작하신 분들은 어떻게 보면
저는 시작하자마자 막 돈을 버는
거보다 그렇게 한번 아뜨거하면서
어 아 주식이 이런 거구나 좀 경험을
먼저 한번 하시는게 오요. 정말
다행이라는 생각 들다. 최근에도 많은
분들이 주식 안 하다가 이제 좀 해
보려고 한다면서 많이 시작을 하셔든
>> 예예. 그래서 초심장의 행운처럼
시작하자마자 한 6개월 이렇게 돈을
너무 쉽게 버는 걸로 착각을 하시면
결국 조금으로 조금 투자해서 번 걸로
자신감이 생겨서 큰 돈을 투자했을
때가 나중에 크게 손실 날 수 있기
때문에 저는 지금과 같이이 조정이
오는게 다행이라는 생각을 하고
있습니다. 주식이라는 거는 이렇게
단동성이 큰 자산이다.
그래서 제가 얘기한게 주식 투자의
본질은 대중들이 인지하고 있지 못하는
기업 가치의 변화에에 투자를 하는
거고 또 내가 투자하는 자산의
변동성에 대한 충분한 공부로 해서
위험 관리까지 하는게 투적이 뭔지라고
말씀드렸었는데
최근에 보면 대중들이 인지하고 있지
못한 기업 가치의 변화가 아니라
모두가 다 인지하고 모두가 다
좋다라고 하는 거에 어
>> 그러니까 확신이 들잖아요. 다 좋다고
얘기합니다. 네. 그렇게 투자했을
때에 반드시이 변동성을 통해서 그렇게
어설프게 투자하는 사람들의
확 털고 예 주식가가 다시 올려가기
때문에 그 언제 투자하면 먹냐? 아주
공포스럽
>> 그 공포의 크기만큼 수익률이 난다고
했잖아요.
>> 예.
그 부분을 이번에 어 만약에 배우시게
되면 평생 투자하시는데 큰 도움이 될
거예요.
>> 네. 오늘 어 시작은 시장은 어떻게
지금 전개되고 있습니까?
>> 네. 어 시작은 -2.66%로
하락해서 출발을 했고요. 현재
-3.1%입니다.음
>> 7,352까지
-3.96까지이 구류까지 밀렸다가
지금 또 약간의 반발 매수세가 약간
들어오는 그런 모습이고 호스닥은
어떻게 되고 있어?
>> 코스닥 -1.79%
하락해서 출발했고요. 현재
-3%입니다.
>> -3%까지.
보통 반대 매매가 들어오면 어 많이
빠진 내 종목 계좌에 있는 내 종목만
반대 매매가 들어오는게 아니라 그
계좌가 통째로 반대 매매가 나
>> 맞습니다. 예, 맞습니다. 그래서
예,
>> 마지막에
그 바닥을 칠 때는 아니이 주식은
오르지도 못한 주식인데이 이런 것까지
왜 빠지지?
그리고 최근에 강세를 보였던
종목조차도 신고가 나는 종목조차도
마지막이 바닥 국면에서는 아 신고가가
나니까 신고가 주식도 좀 사놨던
그 계좌가 통째로 반대 매매가 나오다
보니까 강했던 주식도 이렇게 빠지는
모습이 나와야 그게 좀 바닥이
그런 현상이 좀 나올 수도 있으니까
참고하시길 바라겠습니다. 습니다.
자, 오늘 밤 미국 시장 어제 미국
시장은 다 마이너스 난다라고
하셨던 거 같은데 아니네. 그 최부
사장님은 필방 마이너스 날 것 같다.
>> 예.
>> 그리고 SMP 500 마이너스 나스닥
플러스. 그러니까 우리 장프로가
플러스 주천프는 마이너스. SP
그렇게 다 마이너스였죠. 거지. 예.
>> 오늘 7월 8일 수요일 오늘 밤 미국
시장은 어떻게 될지 장로부터 얘기
한번 해 보시죠.
>> 나스닥 하락입니다. 하락.
>> 네.
>> 네. 어떤 이유? 아무래도 중독
이슈도 있고 채권도 좀 올라주는
모습이라서
상승하긴 좀 어렵지 않을까 생각해서
바라겠습니다.
SP 500은 어떻게 될 거 같
>> 오늘까지는 하락이 이어진다.
>> 이어질 것 같습니다.
>> 비슷한 이유로.
>> 네.
>> 특별히 살 이유를 못 찾았 것 같아서
>> 아직까지는.
그래도 미국 주식도 보면 사야 될
만한 주식들은 보이기는 보이는 거
같아. 종목별로 종목별로네.
>> 지수 ETF 배팅을 할 건가 말
건가는 음
>> 예 금리 추위를 좀 보면서 더
확인해야 되겠지만 일반은 어떻게
될까?
저는 상승인데요.
이유는
이전의
뭐 경험치나 어떤 통계치로 봤을 때
12에서 한 15% 정도 필반이
빠지면 약간 가격 매력하고 단기 가격
매력하고 밸루에이션 매력이 좀 어
생기는 구간이었기 때문에 지금 나온
뭐 메타발리니어
인프라나 삼성전자 실적 발표 세론
ADR 상장
뭐 유가 상승, 금리 상승이 있지만이
다 새로운 뉴스는 아니고 어떻게 보면
이제 하락을 설명하기 위해서 확대
재생산되는 그런 측면이 제가 볼 때
좀 있는 거 같거든요. 그래서 저는
오히려 펀더멘탈리 해 가지고
가격 매력, 단기 가격 매력, 단기
밸루에이션 매력 어 그리고 어 과거
최근 올해 있었던 필반 지수 하락
대비해서 어 일어났던 패턴 요런 것들
좀 감안했을 때 단기 반등이 나오지
않을까 그렇게 생각합니다.
제가 회의 들어오기 전에 미국 시장
뭐 해외 시장까지 한번 쭉
보고 들어왔었거든요. 그런 거 보고
들어왔는데
어 필반 지수요
차트만 보더라도 14,65까지
갔다가 어제 경우에 딱 60일 이평을
딱 찍고 살짝 밑꼬리 달고 끝나세요.
그죠?
>> 네.
>> 예. 그러면
중동발 이슈 정도 가지고는
>> 시장은 안 밀린다고 했잖아요.
>> 단기적으로 놀라긴 놀래도
그래서 일봉으로 보면 일단은 반등
구간에는 들어갔다. 여기서 아까
매수할 이유가 좀 없다라고 했었는데
어 테크니컬 어 테크니컬하게 매매하는
선수들 입장에서는 뭐요 자리에서 한번
사 봐야 되거든요. 그런 자리기
때문에
매매 공방이 조금 치열하게 일어날 거
같고
중동에서 이런 거 있으면 하루이
빠지더라도 그날에 또 반등이 들어가
그런 모습이 많았기 때문에
>> 저도 조심스럽게
오늘밤 미국 시장은 살짝 반등
들어가지 않을까
>> 그 전이 됩니다. 그래서 오늘
우리나라 시장은 오전에는 어제 미국
시장을
반영하고 또 반대명에 있는 것 때문에
좀 정확한 모습이 좀 나오더라고요.
입장 들어가서는 약간 당겨 놓고
끝나지 않을까 그런 생각도 죠.
그래서 오늘 양봉인지 음봉인지
어떻게 돼요?
>> 어제 코스닥은 얘기했죠. 네. 오늘도
같은 한봉으로 나왔습니다.
>> 오늘도 음봉.
>> 네.
>> 잠깐만. 코스닥이 아까 얼마시다
했었?
>> -1.
>> 어 베이너스 1.8%입니다.
>> 1.8%
>> 네.
>> 아 어제도 장중에
쫙 올라갔다가 결국 어 시장 분위기
자체가
삼성전자 하이겠죠.
>> 예. 그렇습니다. 예. 쭉 밀리다
보니까 신형 분위기 센티멘트가 좀
악화되면서 결국 어제 음봉으로 가.
>> 최근에 하나, 둘, 셋, 넷 나올
연속 다 음봉 나왔네요.
하나 둘 셋 넷
바로 앞전에도 5월 달에 조정 받을
때도네 번 연속 음봉 나오고 그다음에
기술 반등 들어왔는데
오늘까지는
>> 네.
겁니다.
스스닥은
고점 대비 지금 34% 빠졌습니다.
5월 고점대 34% 빠졌고 코스피는
어떻게 됩니까?
어제 고스피
>> 어제 음봉했었습니다.
>> 어제 음봉
오늘
볼린저 하단에 다 왔거든요.
일봉상으로. 네.
어,
오늘은 그래도 양봉 날 가능성이
음봉보다는 좀 더 높지 않을까라는
생각이 듭니다. 그래서 양봉해
보겠습니다.
>> 어, 오늘 양봉.
>> 네.
>> 음.
보니까 앞전에
전쟁이 터지고 20일선을 강하게 1년
만에 깼다가 반등이 쭉 들어오는
모습이
3월 18일 정도까지 안등이 쭉
들어왔다가
그러고 나서 한 5,900 거의 6천
회복하는데 했다가 다시 빠지면서 3월
말에 50,52
그때 때 여기 60일 이평금을 깨고
끝났어. 깨고 끝났는데 그다음 날부터
갭상승으로 시작해 가지고 쭉 반등에
들어가는 그런 모습이 나왔는데 지금
오늘 61 이평이 깨졌어요. 61
이평이 7,639.
그래서 기술적으로 보면 오늘 같은
경우에는 되게 매수하고 싶은
고점 대비 9,385 대비해서는 지금
- 21%까지
빠져 있는 그런 상태입니다.
자, 아까 말씀드린 대로 어
주식이라는게 왜
주식 투자로 어 쉽게 돈을 못 벌게
만들어냐면
주식으로 쉽게 돈 벌면 누가 이하요?
일을 하냐는 거죠.
>> 반도체는 누가 만들고 자동차는 누가
만들고는
>> 누가 키우고
>> 그래서 저는 어 주식을 하면서 주식
투자로 어설프게 공부해 가지고
분위기에 휩쓸려서 투자를 해서 어
절대 주식으로 돈 못 벌게 만들어
놓은게 모든 세상 이치 똑같다는
거죠. 축구 선수 대충 연습 좀 몇
번 하고 프로 선수 되는 거
아니잖아요. 그죠. 그렇죠. 타쿠
선수도 마찬가지로
잠깐 프로타쿠가 있나? 전
>> 프로타고
>> 근데 그 기업체에
>> 기업체에 소속된 선수들은 있으니까
그러니까이
변동성에 대한 부분을 어 내 계좌의
손실과 손익 여으로 떠나서 이번에 좀
좋은 공부한다 생각하시고
정 마음이 허면네
DB 투자 증거 테란노인들 DB 투자
증거 가서 오늘 어떤 분이 어머니
전시에나 갔다 와야 되겠습니다 하는데
저희 어머니 전시에 가서 작품 보시면
마음이 아주 차분해지실 겁니다.
어머니 오늘가 계시냐고 제가
여쭤봤더니
오늘은 12시부터 거의
5시까지나가 4시까지는
계신다고 하니까 예 마음이 허하신
분들은 가셔 가지고
>> 예
>> 작품 보시면서 서회랑 미나로 되어
있는 작품이니까
달리시면서이 변동생장을
이겨내는시기 바라겠습니다.네 네,
오늘 체슬링 모닝 브리프 7월8위
수열 순서는 여기까지 하겠습니다.
저희와 함께 항상 행복하고 쓸기롭고
네,
지혜로운 조하시길 바라겠습니다.
고맙습니다. 감사합니다.